Come to order.
I'm going to talk about what our order of affairs is today.
We will take, since we got out of order yesterday, we will take up item 8 first, that concerns charter waivers.
Then we will take up item 5, which is a carryover from yesterday.
That's the update on our assessment system.
After item 5, we will take up non-classroom charters, which is item 7.
So 8, 5, 7.
And then the consent calendars, the waivers first, the regular consent second.
And then the last two items for today are that we will take up item nine, SBE priorities, and finally general public comment, item 21.
So those are the areas that we will go with.
And is there any clarity needed on that?
Okay, so all right, I think we're now ready for item eight on the charter waivers.
Cindy Chan will present for the department on this item and we will proceed.
Your screen went blank.
I don't know, is the screen supposed to go blank?
I'm not using a PowerPoint.
Good morning.
Good morning Board President Kerr, Superintendent Torvikson and members of the board.
I'm Cindy Tan.
Not on.
Hello.
Can you hear me?
They need to turn it up.
Your voice is so soft.
Okay, I'm Cindy Chan, Director of the Charter Schools Division at the California Department of Education.
Item 8 is a new State Board of Education proposed policy proposal for waivers of select education code provisions specifically for non-classroom based charter schools that operate a resource center outside of its authorizing district but within the county.
Provisions in charter school law that address geographic restrictions for the operation of non-classroom based charter schools are the subject of this proposed policy.
So I'm going to start with just briefly sort of listing or reading off the specific Ed Code sections.
I'll then touch on the need for waivers that we are bringing to you and any waiver conditions as well as the purpose of the policy.
So the provisions in question are, there are four main ones.
The first provides that a charter school petition shall identify a single charter school that will operate within the geographic boundaries of the authorizing school district.
A charter school may propose to operate at multiple sites within the authorizing school district.
if each location is identified in the charter petition.
Limited exceptions to these restrictions are allowed, including a charter school may establish one site outside the school district boundaries but within the county where it has attempted but wasn't able to locate within the geographic boundaries of the authorizing school district or for temporary use during construction or expansion.
And lastly, a charter school may establish a resource center, meeting space, or other satellite facility located in an adjacent county to that in which the charter school is authorized and use exclusively for educational support of non-classroom based independent study provided certain conditions are met.
A specific case in Shasta County was litigated involving a non-classroom based charter school that operated a resource center outside the geographic boundaries of its authorizing school district, but within the same county.
The school district where the resource center was located brought suit contending the location of the resource center within their boundaries was in violation of law.
On December 2nd, 2014, the Shasta County Superior Court issued a statement of decision that supported the charter school's argument that a resource center, meeting room, or other satellite facility is not a site or school site, and therefore not governed by the geographic restrictions of charter schools.
This decision was appealed to the Court of Appeal, 3rd Appellate District, which I'll refer to as 3rd District throughout my presentation.
About four months ago, on November 16, 2016, the 3rd District reversed the lower court ruling and held that the geographic restrictions apply to all charter schools, including non-classroom based charter schools, unless one of the exceptions that I noted applies.
Most recently, a couple of months ago, on January 18, 2017, the California Supreme Court denied review of the 3rd District's opinion, which thus became final as of that date.
Therefore, in order to ensure compliance with this final court ruling or opinion, a charter school resource center must operate within the boundaries of its authorizer unless an exception applies or in an adjacent county.
So the need for the waivers that we are bringing forward to you as part of the policy, I'll give you a little bit of background here.
The statutes in question were enacted almost 15 years ago, remaining relatively unchanged over the years.
We feel it's important to acknowledge that during this time, the geographic restriction provisions were interpreted differently by the department and by other respected agencies and LEAs.
And this interpretation was counter to the court's final decision.
Information to that effect was publicly disseminated to local educational agencies.
While the third district did not find this to be persuasive in their decision, we find that non-classroom based charter schools may have relied upon and operated for many years under an interpretation of the statutes that are in conflict with the final court decision.
The CD recognizes and respects the third district's decision, which became final on January 18th of this year.
The major timing of the decision's final status, however, may be problematic for some schools to come into immediate compliance.
There are a number of compliance options for these charter schools, including closing the resource center and transitioning students to enroll in another school, relocating the resource center, or seeking a new charter petition within the district of location or petition of a countywide charter.
Noting that some of these options may require additional time.
Guided by the third district's decision, the CDE proposes including parameters that any waiver be applicable to only existing non-compliant resource centers of non-classroom based charter schools and for the limited purpose of providing charter schools operating non-compliant resource centers time to comply with the decision in order to minimize disruption to pupils and educational programs.
Furthermore, the CDA may recommend conditions to the waiver that may include, but not be limited to, require the charter school's governing body to approve a transition plan that details how the charter school's resource centers will come into compliance with the third district's decision, require the charter school to submit the transition plan to the charter school's authorizer within 30 days after approval of the waiver,
If the authorizer has not visited the resource center, which is required pursuant to statute, require that the authorizer visit the resource center within a reasonable time frame.
The waiver may not be permanent, limited to a period of not more than two years, less two days, and the waiver shall not be retroactive.
So lastly, I'll just discuss the purpose of the policy that is an attachment one.
So the main purpose of the policy is to provide guidelines for both the department and the state board to evaluate the waiver requests.
Also, because we believe there will be a large submission of these requests, the policy also serves to facilitate management of the workload for both the department and the state board's agenda.
Additionally, some chartering authorities have opined that they do not have knowledge of some or all resource centers operated by their charter schools.
Therefore, we find additional information be provided which we feel is both prudent and necessary to support any recommended conditions.
For each non-compliant resource center, the following information would be required.
The physical address of each Resource Center, the school district in which each Resource Center is located, the date each Resource Center was established, the number of students attending each Resource Center, and the need for the waiver.
As you know, information and comments that you may have received or that you may hear this morning from concerned and interested parties represent very vastly different perspectives and positions on this matter, all of which we find to be compelling and important in that regard.
However, the CDE finds to be of most importance that compliance with the decision should be balanced with mitigating any negative impact to affected pupils.
As such, the intent of the waiver policy and any subsequent waiver requests are to ensure charter school compliance with the court opinion
while also recognizing and allowing schools that time may be needed, albeit limited, for thoughtful transition to reach compliance with the intention of minimizing any impact and disruption to their pupils.
Therefore, the CD recommends that you approve the non-classroom based charter school resource center location waiver policy in attachment one.
Thank you.
OK, we're ready for board member discussion of issues that they want clarified.
I'm sure we'll have public comment.
So do we want some additional board member discussion?
Yeah, liaisons.
Do you want to speak now or wait for public comment?
Oh, Pat.
Do you want to talk now or wait for public comment?
OK, public.
Let's have the public comment.
Would the following people please line up?
Laura Preston, Ken Burt, Enrique Rauchio, Lisa Kaur, Jennifer Kausa, Megan Macy, Tim Azevedo, Rick Faust, Andrew Donovan, William Tunnick, Angelina Gutierrez, Michelle Lynch, and Todd Odo.
Good morning, my name is Enrique Arracho, and I'm here on behalf of the Los Angeles Unified School District, mainly to urge that the State Board of Education not to approve the proposed charter school location policy.
I apologize, I ran over here.
In addition to many of the points raised in the letter jointly submitted to the board last Friday, we wish to highlight our concern that adoption of this waiver policy would contravene and undermine California's confidence and investment in local control as embodied in the landmark LCFF legislation and numerous other actions taken since then.
As this body has acknowledged many times, local school districts are best positioned to know, understand, and weigh the complex needs and interests of the students, families, and communities we represent and serve.
Yet, this policy would essentially exclude the local school district
with geographic jurisdiction from the waiver process and decision.
Altogether, we therefore urge the board to require the written consent of any school district in which the charter school seeks to continue to operate before approving any waiver requests that would extend beyond the 2016-2017 school year.
Time.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Tim Azevedo and I'm the superintendent of the Anderson Union High School District.
My district is the one referenced in the court case that has started this entire discussion.
First, I want everyone to know that our court case was not an anti-charter movement, it was simply an effort to clarify the law in question and ensure that all parties are following the law as it exists.
This journey has been over three years in the making and a notable expense to my district, but we finally have an answer.
When the decision was released earlier this school year, all the superintendents in our county agreed that we would not force the illegally operating charters out immediately, but allow them to finish the school year so as not to disrupt the students in the middle of the year and to give charters ample time to secure an appropriate facility within their authorizing district.
However, they would need to relocate within their authorizing district prior to the opening of the 17-18 school year.
That allowed them in excess of eight months to correct the problem.
Having said all that, here we are contemplating a two-year grace period to correct something that has been 100% clarified to be illegal.
We teach our students to obey the law.
That's it.
Thank you.
My name is Rick Foss.
I'm superintendent of three districts.
Two are very, very small.
And Redding School District is my primary employer.
We authorize three charters.
So I understand charters.
I'm pro-charter.
This waiver would essentially go contrary to what we believe was well thought out through the appeal process.
And we believe that people should operate within their district.
That's been the law for a long time.
It's clearly been interpreted.
And it absolutely, in our case, we have a district of about 25 students 40 miles away from the Resource Center that has about 200 students within two blocks of my district office.
That really isn't the intent of what we were all about when we started the charter movement in the state of California throughout the United States.
It's great for options for parents and for kids.
We totally believe in it, but it should operate within the district.
unless it meets one of those exceptions, which this clearly does not in our case.
We thank you for your support and thank you for your time.
Good morning, Megan Macy with Lozano Smith.
In addition to the letter that was submitted by my firm on behalf of nine school districts statewide on this issue, I just wanted to point out two items from that letter and kind of history on this in the case.
And the first is that this board back in July took action on the Audio 2 petition and
punted the issue on the question of location until after there was a court decision, which we now have and we understand what the law is.
It would be the request of these districts that there's kind of follow through on following the court's opinion here and not granting these waiver requests.
Secondly, I'd urge the board to consider the discussion of 47602 in the Ed Code and whether or not these provisions of law can actually be waived at all.
And that's set forth in the letter.
So thank you again for your time and action on this item.
Good morning.
My name is Andra Donovan.
I'm general counsel for San Diego Unified School District.
You received a letter jointly on behalf of a number of districts and our behalf and you received a separate letter from me directly.
I won't belabor the points in those letters except to emphasize that not only do we not believe that this is a valid waiver under the education code because it completely undermines
the provisions of law that were added by the 2002 amendment to the CSA, the Charter School Act.
But we see no reason why there should be a two-year grace period for these charter schools to come into compliance.
Any charter school that has a valid program can submit a petition to our district if they choose to operate there.
They have plenty of time to do that before the 17-18 school year.
They also have plenty of time to let their families know that they may need to make different decisions before the end of the 17 school year.
I'm sorry, before the beginning of the 17-18 school year.
Unfortunately, the truth is that schools close often and families have to make decisions.
We've been litigating this case for five years now.
We are close to a decision in our child court case against Julian and Julian Charter School and Diego Valley Charter School before you right now.
Thank you.
Good morning, I'm William Tunick with Dennis Oliver Kelly appearing on behalf of several school districts which oppose the approval of a policy which would allow charter schools to continue to operate in violation of the Education Code.
We've previously submitted comments on opposition of this policy but wanted to quickly highlight three legal concerns.
First, the policy applies to a class of waivers and implements law administered by the board, thus it's a regulation and has to be promulgated pursuant to the Administrative Procedure Act.
Second, the policy attempts to extend the board's waiver authority to charter schools, which is not authorized by the education code.
And third, the board's waiver authority cannot be used to undermine the legislature's intent, in this case, the necessity for local control and oversight of charter schools.
Waiver of key components of the Charter Schools Act cannot be allowed to use to allow continued violation of a law that's been in existence for 15 years and which is key to the constitutionality of the act.
Therefore, we'd ask the board to reject the proposed policy and appreciate your time this morning.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Jennifer Kaza.
I'm the executive director of Julian Charter School, and I totally agree with everything Ms.
Chan just said about the waivers.
We have a lot of work to do.
I have four charters that I'm writing.
I need to get into a new SELPA, which takes over a year.
to be able to apply for a SELPA in order to get status to be able to cover the majority of my resource centers.
And I need time in order to do this maneuver.
And most districts are telling me I need to turn in a charter by November in order to open the following school year.
So it is not enough time from March to June to open a charter in the following school year.
Good morning.
My name is Lisa Corr, one of the attorneys with Young, Menny & Corr.
I want to thank you and the staff for such hard work on the policy.
We support the policy.
We provided one letter in general support of the policy, and then last night, a late letter in opposition to Lozano-Smith's letter.
The board absolutely has the authority to waive Section 47605 and 47605.1.
The Education Code provides general waiver authority unless there is an absolute exception in the law.
There are two specific exceptions in the Charter Schools Act to the waiver authority.
One is to a singular paragraph related to the numbering of charters, and one is to the instructional minutes.
Therefore, it is not the fact that the entirety of the Charter Schools Act cannot be waived.
The transition time is so necessary for my clients, all of which are under
what has been a constant threat of litigation.
Special education services and standardized testing are just two critical actions that occur at these resource centers.
I urge you to approve the policy.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Todd Odo.
I'm the superintendent of Visalia Unified School District in Visalia, California.
In VUSD, we've had much experience with charter schools.
We have dependent charter schools in our district, five of them, and also experience chartering independent charter schools.
Our experience is that charter schools work best when they are a partnership among the community, the chartering school district, and the charter school itself.
We have a charter school in our boundaries that falls within the purview of the policy under consideration today.
We oppose the policy that's before you now as it's currently structured.
We have not been contacted by that school regarding the issue before you today regarding the possibility of charting within our boundaries, which is the ultimate resolution.
It strikes us that there is no crisis here that would suggest that a waiver issued directly from the State Board of Education is the best solution.
Instead, we ask that you postpone this decision at least and use the resulting time to develop a policy that provides a process for input from local districts impacted by this policy.
In short, we believe that the board's approval of a policy that provides for application for a waiver directly to you, in that case, we lose the opportunity to build relationships with charter schools that are necessary for their success.
Thank you.
Good morning, Michelle Lynch on behalf of the California Charter Schools Association.
We want to thank the staff for their work on this waiver policy and urge you to approve it today.
This decision in Shasta has been a stark change from a general understanding between charters, many authorizers, and even the State Department of Education on the interpretation of the law.
And we do see that there will be a lot of disruption to students.
And we really hope that today you take action to approve this waiver policy to allow our schools to come into compliance with the law and give the students an opportunity to continue to be served as they currently are.
Thank you.
Good morning Angelina on behalf of Los Angeles County Office of Education.
It is crucial that the members of the State Board of Education devise a course of action that adheres to the ruling of the Third District Court of Appeals.
It is imperative that these charter schools either take immediate action to come into compliance with the law or end their operation as soon as possible.
We feel strongly that any waivers granted by the board be valid for no longer than one year.
This would provide the charter school with ample time to either come into compliance or cease operation, thereby providing students currently enrolled in these schools the time necessary to seek out an alternative education placement as necessary.
Prior to the Anderson ruling, many of the charter schools impacted by the court's decision were aware that the placement of charters outside of the authorizing district boundaries was a questionable practice.
Now that the case law corroborates those warnings, we encourage you to reinforce the court's ruling and abide by the spirit of the law.
By enacting a waiver period of no more than one year, the board would strike a fair balance for all stakeholders.
Thank you.
Hi, Angela DeRamos representing California Teachers Association.
The California Teachers Association is opposed to the adoption of item eight.
Consistently with the law, the granting of charters shall only be through school districts with democratically elected school boards within the boundary of the school district.
Therefore, this waiver proposal would continue to take or delay the local control of the district.
Further, the state board, as a matter of public policy, should not interfere with the court's determination in this matter.
It is not necessary to adopt this waiver policy, which appears to be pro forma and is essentially a get out of jail free card for two years.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
We support the waiver policy as well.
This is a huge problem.
We appreciate the work that staff on the State Board and Department side have put into this.
Waiver criteria are fairly clearly specified in law.
We would urge you to use those along with the policy.
going forward do the same.
We have quite a few of our members, not a ton, but several, including some fairly large ones that are currently facing what you would call a cease and desist letter telling them to shut their operations immediately.
Obviously, this would be extremely disruptive if they were to do that for all the people involved.
So we strongly support the policy and look forward to working on you with the waivers in May.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Thank you for the opportunity to address you.
My name is Bill McCabe.
I'm the superintendent of Lassen Union High School District.
I would urge, I've already provided you with a written comment, but I'd urge you not to approve this today.
Making a policy of this nature, I think, really needs a lot of thought.
and interaction and collaboration from the field, and to take action today I think would be appropriate.
I'd encourage you to postpone the decision at the very least, although I am totally opposed to it.
We aren't even talking about quality issues and the fact that some charters
in my area have no possibility of ever coming in compliance with the law, and yet we give them, as pointed out by a prior speaker, a get-out-of-jail-free card.
I think districts are reasonable.
It was stated earlier, and I've stated this to charters too, that we'd make a reasonable transition, and now leverage has been provided by the Department of Education to say, hey, it doesn't matter, let's not talk, let's just thumb our nose to
cooperative community efforts.
Good morning, President Kurst, members of the board.
Barrett Snyder representing the Newhall School District and four other districts in the Santa Cruz Valley.
They, over the last couple of years, have had some issues with a local district citing charter schools inside the geographic boundaries of their district.
We've been involved in some legislative efforts around this issue.
And to that effect, we support the staff's position and recommend that you, for the purposes that articulated well by, I would say, by LACO in particular, but really consider that one year limit and not open up for two years.
I think one year would give folks ample amount of time to do it, but we got to give kids an opportunity to land somewhere.
Thank you.
Thank you, members of this board.
My name is Tristan Brown with the California Federation of Teachers.
We represent 120,000 educators, including many of those who work at charter schools.
We'd like to echo the comments by the L.A.
County of Ed.
We believe that there are there does need to be a reasonable time for transition.
However, that these locations should comply with the law as soon as possible.
One year should be adequate enough to provide notice to parents and students that a move or change is necessary and that that would compel them to come in
to the bounds of the law and respect the sanctity of the local control that has become the landmark of our public education system.
And we hope that this also forces more congruity between the charter system and local control.
So, thank you very much.
Okay, that's the end of the public testimony.
So, now we're ready for our liaison to make some comments.
Board Member Rockmon.
First of all, I want to thank all of the stakeholders and representatives who came here to talk about this policy and to have a conversation today.
on this issue.
I also want to thank and recognize the folks on all the groups that sent letters to the board with conversations and expressing very clearly and very coherently what their concerns are about the implementation of the court's ruling.
And while there was a broad number of issues that were raised, not only today by the people who testified and in a lot of the written letters, the purpose of this item is not to re-litigate the arguments that were settled by the decision in the appellate court.
And so we're not going to sit, it doesn't make sense to sit and parse out whether or not there is, whether or not the court made the right decision.
That's not the board's responsibility, nor is it their authority.
It's the board's response and the waiver itself, this policy does not nullify any of the board's existing authority concerning charters or any of the concerns
that the board hears on charter policies.
The objections that are raised both in the letters concern the language of the policy and whether or not the policy accurately interprets the statute and the ruling of the court.
The purpose of this policy is to ensure that we
act in a uniform way and create a clear and transparent uniform process to focus on what everyone agrees is the clear need to come into compliance, to create a reasonable transition, a reasonable transition process and a reasonable period and to minimize the disruption to students who benefit from the services provided by these resource centers.
This policy is intended to define a course of action to bring us into compliance with how the clear intent of the court's ruling interprets the statute.
The statute is clear about the exemptions.
There will still be resource centers that can operate with those exemptions as enumerated in the law.
So that is not changed.
But we did hear and we do understand that there is some language that should be considered and there were three
changes that we are recommending to make the policy clear and to address some of the more strident concerns that were raised by a number of letters.
We are recommending that we change the term from two years less two days to one year or basically until June 30th, 2018.
So, the term would be one year and six weeks.
We're also recommending the language be amended to require the charter school to submit a copy of the transition plan to all districts where the resource centers are located.
And we're also recommending adding language to require the charter school to provide a status update to parents.
Let me just say the staff from both of the state board and the department
We're very diligent, not only in studying the Anderson decision, but taking a clear look at the statute and understanding that there are some charters that are going to have some concerns that need to be, and they will need assistance to make sure that they are able to aptly
and quickly accommodate this transition.
So I'm very pleased to say that the staff did not do this in a flippant or inconsistent way.
They were very thoughtful in the process.
We spent a great deal of time thinking this through.
and parsing out each sentence, each verb, each semicolon, each period to try to make sure that our policy did not change the interpretation, expand on the board's authority, or re-litigate concerns that have clearly been resolved by the court.
Thank you.
Okay, so let me go, you're recommending, so you're personally recommending one year rather than two?
Is that what I heard?
Based on the feedback we've received, I will talk with the staff and we are recommending that we change the transition period from two years to one year and six weeks.
Okay, so we... Plus the other two changes.
Yeah.
Okay, do our...
Any other board comments on this change?
Board member Williams.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
So that's a recommended, those three things are recommended to be added.
I would be interested in particular in hearing other board members talk about the time period.
I agree with the plan.
I agree with the notifying parents and making sure they're kept informed all along the way as to what's going to happen so they have ample time to move their children if they need to move their children.
I am inclined to two years to make it happen, but I am open to the shorter amount of time.
But what I am concerned about is that June 30th, I don't know the calendars of these schools.
And if they have children in school in June,
which many schools do, then some additional amount of time, if we were to go with a shorter amount of time, maybe through July or August, to wrap down things, get out of leases, get out of whatever else they have, and set up the next thing, if there is going to be a next thing, feels more comfortable to me and still keeps it at one academic year.
So that's just something for your consideration.
Or state superintendent.
Just two questions.
I heard comments from the audience.
One is just we've checked and we do have the legal authority to do waivers.
There was a question raised by one of the district's attorneys.
Yes, we've
Judy Sias with the State Board Legal Counsel.
Yes, we've checked.
I mean, of course, everything with charters is open to debate, but yes, we have granted waivers of the Charter School Act in the past.
So that is consistent.
I want to clarify Member Rucker's statement.
All the waivers will be considered on a case-by-case basis when they come in.
This policy does not require any action by the board.
It does not actually require any action by CDE.
It's all permissive.
Each waiver will still be analyzed on a case-by-case basis.
As is the case with any waiver, CDE will make a recommendation.
There will be an opportunity for public comment, and the board can reach a decision.
This does not require any sort of board decision or require anything like that.
Thank you.
And the other question I had that came from one of the superintendents, I think it was Visalia, suggesting that if the charter wants to continue, but the timeframe is tight under the format they have today, is there a viable option to appeal and apply to the local school board and get a charter through that mechanism, which keeps them viable serving students?
Right, and I think that's many options that the charters are going to have to consider.
They're going to have to, in some cases, they might consolidate the resource centers.
Maybe what they'll do is they'll submit, I think one of the charter schools testified that she was in the process of submitting petitions to the districts where the resource centers are located.
Maybe they qualify for one of the exceptions.
So there are options.
I believe June 30th, and I want to clarify,
Pat and I discussed, I said, here's what I think the letters are going to go.
So we, I had given her a list of, I summarized the letters for her.
It wasn't necessarily changing the staff recommendation, but we had talked about it.
June 30th was suggested because that's usually in the letters, I believe, because it's usually the end of the charter term.
So then it was sort of a clean, and I believe that's why the letters, it was based on what we had read in the letters.
Eileen, Board Member Strauss.
Let me just say, I just want to thank all the all the public that came, the superintendents who I know many of you came a long way to come to our meeting and to talk about supporting students in these programs, but to give it a reasonable time for transition.
And I would say in March right now, June 30th now is not a reasonable enough time.
It's too short based on all the complications.
I mean, you could do it.
But I do think two years is really long.
And I think
I think given the charge of what you need to do, I think a school year, which does go from July 1st to June 30th, is a reasonable amount of time.
I think staff's worked really hard to listen.
I heard quite a bit of support for one year, not two.
And let's transition through the legal process of what they have to do.
So I think I think there are lots of options for the local resource centers to look at, including getting authorized by their local
district where they are in residence.
But I think that gives them a reasonable amount of time.
So I would just say personally as a school and district practitioner I think the one year but June 30th of 2018 gives you a year and a couple of months which is long enough I think to plan to go through your steps and give families opportunities as well as the charter authorizers and the district's time to sort it out.
So I would support
The modified recommendation that Member Rucker recommended.
And again, I think the resource centers do provide good services and I support the work that they're doing.
I just think we need to comply with the court decision and move forward in an appropriate manner.
I do want to make sure that everyone understands that neither the CDE nor the SBE are thumbing their nose at the court decision, not in the least.
The fact is that all of these charter schools must come into compliance, but at the same time a reasonable time frame for that transition makes sense.
primarily because we're dealing with kids.
We're dealing with kids' lives and how they will be disrupted.
Imagine you're a junior in one of these schools right now and your senior year is all planned out already and college is coming up.
It's tough.
So I would support the CDE recommendation with the modifications that Member Rucker has suggested.
Board Member Sun.
And I agree that we are, we do want to comply with the law and our primary concern is with students.
I just wonder if that really is enough time given some of the special education issues.
Is it enough time to transfer?
If we were to go with a modification, I believe that this policy goes until November.
And after that time, we can look at additional requests on an individual basis.
If one of the waivers for this is, if the transition is not able to be done, let's say in the year,
Could the charter school come back and say, well, I've got extenuating circumstances.
This is these additional issues that have come up, et cetera.
And we could consider on one case by case.
Judy, Judy Sias again.
Yes, the charters can always come back for renewal, whether it's two years, less two days, or whether it's June 30th, 2018, there's always an opportunity to come back and renew a waiver request, and then you will have to consider it, and you are correct.
The policy goes away November 2017.
As Cindy talked about, it was sort of designed to deal with the large influx we were anticipating receiving, but again, any waiver received
either as part of this policy or not, will be analyzed on a case-by-case basis.
And, you know, if they have some unique circumstances and or if they come in for renewal at a later date, you all can consider that.
Board Member Williams.
So, just to follow up on a couple of things.
First, I want to reiterate what I've heard and make sure that it's said again for the public record that these charter schools have been operating under what they stood to be understood.
to be the authority to do so based upon even information from CDE and previous superintendents clarifying these questions, that they were not doing anything that they thought was wrong.
But now we know and we know what the decision is and we need to support it.
And that's what the State Board and the CDE are trying to do in the in the fairest way possible.
In addition to worrying about student disruption, I too worry about whether or not there's there's a lot of pieces to operating a school and it's not just can you close and get a new place to rent.
But the cell book question was raised as well.
And in addition to students and their real students and their lives, there's also real teachers and their lives that get impacted when a school gets closed.
And I think someone made the comment that schools get closed all the time, but that's actually not true.
They don't get closed all the time.
That's primarily a situation that charter schools are vulnerable to more than any other kind of school.
So, I do want to make sure if I would agree with Member Ting that a cushion of time is important exactly, whether that's one year and six weeks or whether that's 14 months.
I'm comfortable with it not being two years because I think that we're all in agreement that we want the message to go out clearly that these schools need to comply with the law.
So, we don't want any dawdling on moving forward on that.
the fact that it that if it turns out that's not the right amount of time and we do expect every charter school to take this seriously and start taking action not say oh okay i've got whatever it is 14 months or whatever if it's not the right amount of time i'm hearing that they can come back and and tell us here's all the things we've done to try to make this work and we need just this more amount of time to get that to get that done and that and we could consider that and and i
And I expect from the conversation we're having here that we would only consider that if it looked like a really strong good faith effort was made by the charter school to get that to get that work done.
So the last thing I want to clarify is that all of the charter schools that submit an appeal by the November date, basically you have an offer on the table of whatever it is we agree to today, whether that's two years or no.
That says case-by-case basis?
All waivers are considered on a case-by-case basis.
This is to provide guidance to staff when they're looking at the big pile of waivers.
This discussion will be very helpful to staff, but each waiver will be analyzed on a case-by-case basis, and you guys will look at them all on a case-by-case basis.
So that's not going to be any different if they apply in December for a waiver?
Correct.
This just provides some guidance to staff, what types of conditions that you might find
and some parameters about what the board is thinking around that.
But the ability to come back for a waiver then is clear or to come to us for the first time after the November deadline is open.
Correct.
I'm sorry to interrupt.
This policy would go away in November and each again each waiver would be considered on a case by case basis.
Okay.
Board Member Holliday.
I do want to make sure that none of the charter schools get the impression that we are going to continue to waive this law over and over and over again.
That is not what this policy is about at all.
We are saying you must come into compliance with the law and you must do it soon.
But that soon is, in my mind, the only question that we're really talking about here.
And that soon, as I said, I support Member Rucker's modification, would be June 30th of 2018.
But, you know, I suppose there could be some miraculous reason why we would hear another waiver and consider it.
But this is guidance for staff.
These items could then move to consent.
We could get on with our lives and they could get on with their transition.
All right.
But I do want to make it clear.
We are not in any way encouraging an ongoing waiver process for these schools.
Board Member Burr.
Yeah, I appreciate your comments, Member Holiday, because I wanted to clarify the purpose of the policy, right?
And the purpose of the policy, at least as I see it, is to send a very clear signal to the charter school world, to school districts, to all of their attorneys who are here representing them, what our expectations are with respect to waiver and how long that's going to last.
Everybody has spoken here and I'll just say it out loud as well.
We respect the court decision.
We are under an obligation to ensure that that court decision is carried out in a fair way.
So the waiver policy for people who are paying attention will say, if I want this to happen in a relatively easy way based on the policy the board has happened, I will adhere to the conditions that are in there.
There, as everyone else has said, there may be very specific circumstances where we would want to take it upon ourselves to say, well, we appreciate that.
And in the interest of students and teachers and family members, we would make a different decision.
But this policy will clearly articulate how we feel about this.
And to that end, I also agree with the amendments that member Rucker has put forward.
I would like to have you clarify when we get ready to take action on, I heard the copy of the plan, I think to all districts and to notify parents, but I just want to be clear what those other couple of conditions were.
Thank you.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
I think it's been stated, but I do want to echo what board member Holiday stated.
I don't want to live in waiver land with some of these.
And I think that if we're having this discussion now, it should be in good faith that schools go out and try to seek authorization or find new sites.
And I also support board member Rucker and some of her recommendations for the conditions.
Thank you.
OK, if we're done, maybe our attorney has a comment.
One point of clarification, we received a few emails from districts because we have had some of these waivers.
I believe some were submitted right before the holidays in December.
And we are interpreting, if you adopt this policy, we were, it says in the policy that the waivers were not right for consideration until after the California Supreme Court issued a final ruling.
So the clock on your time to hear the waivers did not start until after California Supreme Court because they were relying on the court opinion as the basis for the waiver that was not final.
So the clock started when?
I'm lost.
January 17th, when California Supreme Court denied review.
That's when the appellate court decision became final.
All right, maybe we're ready to restate the motion then and make a motion in a more formal way.
Okay, so let me begin by saying when I was appointed to the board several years back, six years ago, I asked to be involved in working with staff concerning the waivers.
Not so much because I have no balance in my life or because waivers are not really exciting things.
The fact of the matter is,
When an LEA decides or when a charter school decides to take the step to submit a waiver, it's personal.
It's personal for the LEAs that are submitting the waiver to the board.
It's personal for the stakeholders who are impacted by the board's decision about the waiver.
And it's personal to the staff in both the department and on the board who contact and work personally with districts to understand the issues related to the decision to submit the waiver.
There is a lot of work, a lot of conversation, and a lot of time invested by this board and its agents to do the work of understanding what is the need behind the waiver,
so that when you all see that recommendation, there is a clear understanding, not only from the LEA, but also among the board staff behind the rationale for those recommendations.
And so I wanted to be involved in that process because, for me, it was the most personal way to understand not only the operations of schools, but also why schools need to do the things that they are often asking the board to allow them to do.
So this policy is intended
to further continue that support and continue that relationship, not only with the charters, but with the districts that are authorizing them and are working with them.
This does not nullify the board's position or authority to continue with the charter conversation and with any waivers related to this issue, but it does help with aiding the transition and it sends a clear message to the school community that the board respects the decision that was made by the court.
So I'm making a motion that we accept the staff recommendation concerning implementing and approving this policy.
I'm making three specific recommendations based on the feedback we've received.
I do have them in writing so that it will be and I want to thank the staff for helping me to make sure it's in writing.
The first change or first recommendation is to revise the policy to add language that says
change the term from two years less two days to one year.
Basically, it would be until June 30th, 2018.
So it would be one year in six weeks.
Two, require the charter school to submit a copy of the transition plan to all districts where the resource centers are located.
And three, require the charter school to provide status update to parents.
All right.
Is there a second to that?
Second.
OK.
All right.
Board, if there's no... Is there any further discussion on the motion?
If not, all those in favor, raise your hands.
OK.
That carries unanimously.
Thank you.
Now we're on to item five, which is the carryover item from yesterday.
The assessment CASP update.
Michelle Center will...
present for the department.
So, good morning, Superintendent Torlakson, President Kirks, members of the board.
I will be presenting to you today our CASP update item.
You have not seen me present a CASP update item in a couple meetings.
I know it's hard to believe because I somehow find quite a few items to still present on.
But I have been providing our CASP updates via information memorandum to make sure that the board members are up to date on current information on the CASP system, so I wanted to make sure that everyone was aware of that.
Today as part of my presentation, I do have
Someone who will be assisting me in the presentation on the science assessment.
So Scott Mader from ETS will be joining me for a few slides.
I also want you all to know that if I need to call a friend, I also have friends behind me.
Tony Alpert, Executive Director of the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium is here, as well as Tom Foster, who is the Executive Director and our lead on the CASP contract at ETS.
So what I will be presenting for you is just a subset of all the information that I provided in the lengthy update item.
So I will not be going over everything in that item.
So this is a great image of where we are, right?
We started our summative assessment administration.
It's kind of hard to imagine we're already there.
But the window did open on January 9th.
We did not actually have a test taker until Valentine's Day, February 14th.
And I'm doing a special shout out to Rio Valley Charter School in Lodi, who had a single student test on Valentine's Day and was the first person in California to take the test this year.
So they didn't even know they were being brave.
And as of today, we've had 20,000 tests that have been started in the system.
So a ways to go, but they have until July 17th to complete summative testing.
So we also want to make sure that everyone understands that we get our assessment results back to our LEAs very quickly.
So that's important for us to recognize as we seem to have quite a few conversations on access to data and information.
So let's keep that in mind.
Now, as we go through the system,
we do make sure that we have quality control checks along the way.
So we ensure that all of those quality control checks are completed prior to the quick turnaround starting.
But once that is done, which is usually around May, we usually have enough test takers in the system to do that check, then we start rolling results out on an individual student basis every single night to our districts three weeks after they've completed the test.
So if our districts have set up those accounts for their educators, their educators can log in to the online reporting system and they can get access to those results.
And also want to point out, it's almost time for post-test training.
It just never ends, right?
So once again, the focus will be on using and understanding the summative test results.
And once again, we will have trainers from both ETS as well as WestEd.
It's great that WestEd has partnered with ETS on these trainings.
I think it gives us access to content in those trainings that is really focused on the use of results and options for analyzing that at a local level.
It'll be a full-day workshop, and they will learn how to access their data and how to analyze it as part of their local data review process that supports their improvements in teaching and learning.
It's a free workshop.
And just like last year, and I think this is slowly starting to sink in with our schools and districts, we're no longer offering training just for our CASP coordinators in California.
We're encouraging them to invite other individuals.
And we're starting to see that really take shape in terms of who is attending our trainings and our workshops.
So for example, if they want to bring with them to this a curriculum leader, please do so.
Those are the kinds of conversations that we see taking shape at the tables as we walk around the room that are very powerful, and we've asked them to send those teams again this year to the post-test.
So I'm going to share with you a little bit of data, and this data has been asked for on so many different occasions.
This is the information on accessibility supports for Smarter Balanced.
And before I share the data with you, I want to caution us all against over-interpreting the information I'm going to share with you.
In reality, the test is still in its infancy.
Districts and schools are starting to build out the policies that they need to put in place to make sure that they are identifying the appropriate students, particularly for designated supports, because those policies were not in place before.
We didn't have that category of support before.
So while I'm going to share great news with you, I still suggest that we not overanalyze this information.
You will see a URL on this slide, which I believe you all also have the slide in front of you.
We have been able to post the information I'm going to share at a state level.
Eventually, hopefully by the end of next week, we will update this website with LEA-specific information for two years.
The information that we provide is both the counts of the number of students who were assigned at least one designated support or accommodation.
And it's very important that the use of the word here, assigned, embedded, whichever word you want to use, it is not used.
And that is a big distinction.
I cannot tell via the system whether or not they used the support that was turned on for that student.
So this slide, and I hope it's large enough because I hate that criticism when I hear it from President Kurtz that he can't see it.
So this slide compares.
I can see it.
Oh, good.
So this compares 14-15 to 15-16.
And you'll see a dramatic increase in the number of students assigned accommodations as well as designated supports.
This slide is for ELA that you see in front of you here.
So designated supports for ELA increased by close to 50%.
Approximately 40,000 more students were assigned accommodations in 2016 versus the prior year.
This slide here displays the top five designated supports for ELA and math that grew.
So we see here embedded text-to-speech, non-embedded separate setting.
These are our more popular, if you will, accessibility supports.
Also, before we get too far, I do want to point out that I keep using the term designated support and want to make sure that we understand who has access to a designated support.
That is any student where an educator or team of educators has identified a need.
So that is not only students identified as an English learner, or it could be a student who is reading below grade level, for example.
They could identify supports for that student.
So that's an important distinction, and it's an important philosophy that is behind the accessibility support system that Smarter Balanced has for its assessments.
and we refer to it as accessibility for all.
When we used to have accessibility specifically for students with disabilities, which is of course still there, but now it's accessibility for all.
So on this slide, slide nine, again, we saw a substantial growth in the use of some very specific ELA-designated supports.
So for example, embedded text-to-speech.
So embedded text-to-speech, this is for items, not for reading passages, that assignment grew by 110%.
Non-embedded color overlay grew by 100 percent.
Some of these counts vary in size.
Non-embedded noise buffers grew by 60 percent.
Embedded color contrast grew by 60 percent.
Don't take these growths to indicate that everything grew.
There are some that didn't, but you also saw the overall numbers, which did show an increase.
So we also saw growth in ELA accommodations.
The other slide was designated support.
So for example, embedded text-to-speech for passages now saw a growth of 90%.
Embedded streamline, which is that test interface that simplifies the interface that the student interacts with, increased by 50%.
Non-embedded scribes, that grew by 40%.
So we see quite a bit of growth again, which
which I think means that our training, which we have really overemphasized accessibility in every workshop we've done.
For example, we have our North-South workshops that we do once a year.
It's normally just an update.
We made a special session this year on accessibility, and particularly for designated supports, in particular for EL students.
That was a highlight and a guest speaker that we had come.
So we are making sure that we talk about this topic in every single time we go out.
So slide 11 shows a dramatic increase in the number of students assigned accommodations and designated supports for mathematics.
100,000 more students were assigned designated supports for 15-16 compared to the prior year.
Now this slide is math again and shows the difference between 14-15 and 15-16.
Examples of growth include embedded color contrast grew by 60%, non-embedded color overlay 100% growth.
And again, this slide now is mathematics and accommodations.
And again, you'll see growth there, particularly for non-embedded multiplication tables.
So the other thing I want to highlight as we walk through a little bit of that data is one particular point that came across in the independent evaluation that our independent evaluator, Humro, did on the CASP system.
And one of the things that they pointed out is that there was general consistency between accommodation supports used in the classroom and then what was assigned on the assessment.
So again, moving in the right direction.
Yeah, before you move on to science, that's next, right?
Yes.
Okay.
I wanted to make a comment about this and get this clear because there's been an exchange of letters about compare and information about comparing SAT to the
Smarter Balanced test.
So you need to help me.
But as I, even SAT, I think, acknowledges this.
Our accommodations are embedded in the test.
And the student accesses them that way.
And maybe you could elaborate on that.
My understanding of SAT is it's not embedded in the SAT.
They make accommodations some other way.
And in these exchanges, it gets blurred up by the responses.
So can you lay this out for us, how to give us a better idea?
Because our technology seems to me way above it.
And then SAT says, oh, well, we eject too.
But we're talking about apples and oranges, I think.
So you are correct that we have supports that are embedded within the Smarter Balanced assessment system.
The other thing to point out is that we do have existing within Smarter Balanced a set of experts whose job it is to think about accessibility, know what the current research is, know what technology and devices are coming down the pike,
and continue to improve and add additional accessibility resources as they become available and as research supports them.
And California has always had a representative from the department active on that and actually recently we also have someone from our state special school who's also active on that committee.
When
When we went down the road of developing Smarter Balanced, it was a big transition.
No longer did we have assessments where we had what we referred to as modifications or things that changed the construct and created invalid test scores.
The things that we allow on our assessment are things that are either embedded, and when we use the word embedded, we mean that they are delivered to the student via the testing platform itself,
or non-embedded, which means that maybe they have a multiplication table on hard copy sitting next to them while they test.
But whether it is embedded or whether it is non-embedded, all of those things have been vetted and have been determined not to change the construct and create a valid test score.
I am not an expert on SAT.
I see lots of hands making me nervous.
I don't know what I said.
But I am not an expert on SAT.
Maybe someone out there is, one of my friends who I mentioned was in the audience, who would like to speak on that.
I think that it is not as cut and dry as to what changes the construct in the SAT assessment.
Is there any comment on that by experts?
You have a view on this?
I'm not an expert on the SAT, but I have students who take the SAT and they take the CASP test and have done it for now a couple of years under the new SAT.
And they are very different tests.
They test different kinds of skills.
We've done item analysis on students.
Well, first of all, I was at first excited because if I were to pull back and just look at 90% of our juniors met standards on the CASP and then 90% met whatever the standards on the SAT.
However, if you go down to a more item analysis or you look at it, we see students performing differently on those items.
So that's telling us something about the skills that are required and what the SAT is requiring
versus what the CAHPS is requiring.
So they are very different tests.
Yeah, but I'm pursuing the, we wanted to, in a letter Tom and I sent the regents and CSU was,
that we were trying to make the point that this is an issue of equity.
You know, when you have accommodations built in, this is an important issue of equity.
And then we got, you know, a response which says, well, we do the same thing in effect.
And I, I don't, I don't see how that's possible given the nature of their assessment.
Yes.
And so I actually had a comment on Michelle's presentation.
I am very happy that you are highlighting the increase in the embedded.
Yeah, this is a success for us.
This truly is.
And I would say, yes, your staff has done an excellent job of promoting that, talking about that.
It is an equity issue.
And I'd say what you may all not know is that her staff takes phone calls.
There are so many questions about, well, how does this work and how does that work?
And can we use this?
How does this?
And her staff each year has been very good about responding, being quick to respond because we know testing's coming up.
So I really do appreciate that, that your staff answers phone calls and emails and answers those questions from the field.
And I think also the rise in the
using some of these accommodations is that we weren't sure what the computerized testing would look like and how much it opened the doors to be able to help support students who need that.
So it's really a very, it's a great platform for this.
And as we still build it up and it becomes more robust, I think that
that piece about equity is truly one of the highlights of this new testing system.
All right, good.
And then we had board member Rucker.
Okay, so first of all, I want to echo the compliments that board member Ting has given to the department because I recall last year, I asked for information about the uses for accessibility.
But subsequent to that, I also want to thank the department because you gave me the opportunity to actually sit and talk to the folks who wrote the accessibility guide so that we could have a conversation as a reformed English teacher
about how the guy doesn't really make it clear that it is the intent that these would be universally available to students, not just to a subset of students who would take the test.
And so I think part of the reason why we're seeing an increase
in the number of types of accommodations that were used, teachers understand more what those accommodations are, what those accessibility tools are, and how they actually enhance the end user's interface with the test itself.
Because my initial concern quite some time ago when we went to a computer-based assessment is that you're not just taking a test,
on an electronic tool, there are some end user or interface concerns for the students.
And so these accommodations, these tools help students in that regard.
So seeing that increase, even though we're still in our infancy, also says the field has learned more about using those tools.
And there is a difference that needs to be stated, not just the fact that the tools are embedded, but there are tools universally available to all students
to take this test that the College Board would not want made available to all students in order to take their test.
And it's not because the test itself is not testing proficiency.
This is an entrance exam that is intended to sort and identify certain skill sets.
Now, let's be clear.
As I look around this dais, we are all experts on the SAT because we've taken it at least once.
And even if it's in our distant memory, we do remember the assessment experience.
If I were to ask Michelle to explain to you one of those accommodations
that saw that increase of 100,000 students using it, let me be clear.
Each of the accommodations that she enumerated is not an accommodation the College Board would want to make universally available to every single student
who takes the test.
It is not that the accommodation is a performance enhancing accommodation, but it's just something that would be universally available to all students.
And there is a diversity and a large collection of accommodations that we have never seen available to students before.
just because the technology enhances those options.
And again, that is also the difference.
I suspect that there are things the College Board can do, but if we actually look at and understood what the universe of accommodations that are available because of this technology, it's not just the fact that they are available, but they take advantage not only of the delivery system for the assessment itself, but of the technology that is available to help students participate in taking the test.
So I think it's important to understand that when we want to talk about the differences in the assessment experience between the SAT and the Smarter Balanced Assessment, no, I don't need to be an expert on the SAT.
and what the SAT assesses, but if we actually pay attention to what the accommodations are that are made available to students, those could not be made universally available to students that take the SAT because it defeats the purpose of what the SAT is supposed to be doing.
as a college entrance assessment.
And so I think that while it's a valid conversation to have, there's more to this conversation than just whether or not we want the value of an SAT test with the value of the Smarter Balanced assessment.
There is an apples and oranges comparison,
that goes beyond what the accommodations are.
But at this moment on this item, we're talking about the accommodations.
And if we simply look at the value that is offered for the accommodations to allow more students a fair and equitable access to participate in taking the assessment, then the Smarter Balanced assessment gives us more, with one exception.
I do want to say the guide still needs to help districts understand, especially for the grade 11 assessment, about the calculator.
For those of you who have taken a class that requires you to use a graphing calculator or a calculator where you have to use functions, you've become an expert on using your calculator.
Last year, we knew
And we became aware that there was a problem with the online calculator that was available for Smarter Balanced, and some students probably experienced some problems using that calculator.
It needed to have been known by more people that students had the option to bring their own calculator in to help to use during the test.
Because students are definitely experts on the calculator they spent time using in their algebra, their geometry, or their calculus class.
And they probably had to take some time to learn how to use the online calculator that still had a glitch.
So I think that that still needs to be made clear because even when I visit with districts and I say, well, did you know the room still, the oxygen still gets sucked out of the air in some districts that are hearing that for the first time.
So probably the principal difference between
the two tests is it's really clear when you come to take the SAT, you better bring your calculator.
So I think that there are conversations that are worth having, but as it relates to what we're talking about here with accommodations, there are some key and qualitative differences that require a deeper dive than what we've seen in the letters and in the press right now, because people really don't know what the accommodations are and how they actually work for doing those assessments.
Okay, Board Member Williams.
Just two points.
I really, as I mentioned yesterday, that I have two young men that I advocate for and one of them has an IEP.
And I'm learning a lot that I didn't know.
So understanding the difference between embedded
support, and accommodation.
They often talk about his accommodations with testing, but I don't have any idea what embedded supports they might have used when he took the SAT.
Dangerous thing that I get informed and then I go back to the district or the school and say, so what are you offering?
But it's helpful.
It was helpful and enlightening to me.
to hear you explain that and it's very exciting to see that they're being utilized.
And the second point is that since you opened the conversation about SAT and this test and it took off the conversation, I'm pretty certain we'll be receiving a request from SAT to be able to make a presentation to the State Board on what kinds of things they offer through their testing.
Okay.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
I'm excited to see the increase in all the accommodations and kudos to you and your team for that and raising the awareness.
And I know that what we see is a spike in the request for the accommodations, but we still don't know if they're being used.
And I think that's one of my ongoing concerns because I know that in some districts, some schools, students are not getting to the computer lab, but once a week.
and they may not have the digital skills to really show content and skill, computer skill, when they're taking the assessment.
What are the conversations in the field?
Maybe I'm just exposed to low-income schools or in schools in very economically depressed communities.
But that is one of the ongoing concerns that I hear from educators is the fact that the students just don't have the digital skills because they're not exposed to a computer.
So a lot of our students have phones because that's become a very affordable option, but they're not transferring those skills to a keyboard or just using a tablet, for instance.
So what are we hearing and how are our districts and schools mitigating that?
So I am not hearing concerns from those who are in the classroom with students about their concern about individual students having the skills to interact with the assessment.
But we are hearing a concern about devices in general and whether or not students are getting access to those devices on a day-to-day basis because they are being used for assessment or for other reasons.
So sometimes they may not be available, for example, they may want to give the interim assessment for Smarter Balanced.
And some schools, I think, are struggling with that, even though they want to do it because of the lack of devices or the scarcity of the computer labs.
So we are hearing that.
So can I respond to one thing that member Rucker said?
I will let her know that we are using a different online calculator.
The Desmos calculator was implemented for this year.
This is a new calculator from the first year?
Yes.
Does the student still have the option to bring their own calculator?
The usability guide has not changed on that, but the online calculator is modified and hopefully more user-friendly.
I'm still going to lobby for that.
I know.
Okay.
So, science.
Nice.
So,
Our two science assessments, which is the CAAS, the California Science Assessment, will begin, as well as the California Alternate Assessment for Science, are scheduled to launch March 20th.
So I got a little flustered there because March 20th is right around the corner.
So forgive me, but we're excited, and I want to share with you a little bit of the work that we've been doing, and I also, in a moment, will have someone come up and share with you a couple sample items from the CAS test, and then I will walk you through a sample item of the CAA for science test.
So one of the things I want to share with you is information about the California Science Summit that we recently held.
So ETS, along with CDE, held a summit on March 1st.
The summit allowed us to gather information from experts in both assessment as well as NGSS.
So we had individuals such as Jim Pellegrino from the University of Illinois at Chicago, Kathleen Scalise from University of Oregon, and a note about Kathleen, she works on NAEP science.
Jonathan Osborne and Kathy Sozakowicz, which I'm not sure I pronounced that right, both of them are from SNAP at Stanford.
So those individuals, as well as experts from ETS, as well as department staff and board member and board staff, met with them for an entire day.
And what we promised to do was to learn from our mistakes and to make improvements as we went along the development of our new science tests.
And this summit was one way of doing that.
So we are breaking new ground.
We are facing challenges.
And what we're trying to do is right this ship when need be.
That being said, it was unanimous from the experts in the room.
They felt like we're on the right track.
Not everything we did is 100% correct so far, but they felt like we are on the right track.
And they're very excited about the test that we're developing.
So the new standards are very complicated and challenging just to wrap your head around, honestly.
And so part of the conversation at that meeting was about that exact question, wrapping your head around a set of standards that is complex in its nature.
And I'm not talking about complex in terms of the content it assesses, but how it's organized and how it's structured is very different than anything we've ever had before.
So this is a chance for us, after ETS had started writing items, to come back with these experts and talk openly about, well, these are the items that we wrote aligned to those standards.
What do you think?
What could we have done better?
And they had suggestions for what we could have done better.
And some of those suggestions were specific to how we address the standards and how we align to those standards.
And so we'll be taking that information back and utilizing it as we move forward in development.
So now I'm going to ask Scott Mader to come up and join me.
He's just going to go through, I think, three slides here.
He's an assessment specialist at ETS.
And he'll demo for you a couple items from our CAST assessment.
And just to note, these items that he's going to show you are available publicly on the website in terms of a training test.
Good morning.
I'm Scott Mader from Educational Testing Service.
And as Michelle said, we wanted to bring before you a couple of the items that are out as part of the training test forecast.
And so the item on the left, which hopefully will play as a video.
There we go.
So the item on the left is from the new CAST assessment, and the item on the right is from the CST release test from a number of years ago.
The item on the left, the standard, and I wanted to read you the standard text, says analyze and interpret data to provide evidence for the effects of resource availability on organisms and populations of organisms in the ecosystem.
This is a grade eight item.
The item on the right is actually from the grade 10 CST test.
The standard that it was written to says, students know how to analyze changes in an ecosystem resulting from changes in climate, human activity, introduction of non-native species, or changes in population size.
So some of the same language shows up around analyze,
if you listen to the two standards.
But one of the things that has changed with the NGSS is the clear emphasis on not simply recalling information or applying content information, but truly interacting with data and analyzing the data as you work through an item or doing other skills.
In this case, it's analyzing data.
And so as the video plays, you notice that the students are actually interacting with the item to choose data from the set at the top.
I'm not sure if the video is still, did it play through to the end?
Or did it ever play?
It did scroll down.
Yeah, if it did scroll down, I can see if it'll play again.
This does test my eyesight.
Everybody says.
Yeah, if it doesn't scroll, you can't see the full item.
And that's why I was hoping that it would play as it was supposed to.
There we go.
So the student chooses a scenario of increasing or decreasing resources.
The data is represented in the graphs, those graphs populate.
And then the student analyzes the existing food web and chooses how things might change in response to the scenario they set up at the beginning.
The item on the right in some ways is similar in that there is a food web presented, the students are kind of given a scenario, and then they respond with what changes might have happened in this scenario.
The difference is the way the student can interact with and observe the actual data.
And this is actually a real world data gathered in an Arctic environment that was from a scientific paper that is presented to the students.
So it is a real world example.
So, fundamentally, the difference in the item is less, as Michelle referred to earlier, on the content and much more on the application of skills.
And this is something that can only be done with an online assessment or a hands-on activity, instructional activity in the classroom.
It's very hard to do it with a paper and pencil test, which was what the CST was on the right.
The next item is actually a single item from an item set or performance task.
So there were an additional scenario, and some setup, and an introductory material, and then five previous items before a student would have gotten to this item.
We didn't want to spend as much time showing you all of them.
But again, they are available on the web if you want to see the setup that came before this item.
The item on the left is from the cast.
And again, I'll read the text of the standard.
It says, apply concepts of statistics and probability to support explanations that organisms with an advantageous heritable trait tend to increase in proportion to organisms lacking this trait.
This is about genetics, and it's about how something's good for an organism, more of them appear over time.
The item on the right, which is a CST biology item, says, students know how to predict the probable outcome of phenotypes in a genetic cross from the genotypes of the parents and mode of inheritance.
And then it has some specific examples to limit the types of inheritance.
Again, the focus on the item from a content perspective
Somewhat similar.
The difference is the idea of applying and utilizing data and representing what that output would be with the data.
So again, I'll, if the video will play for me.
Yeah, there we go.
So in this case, the student is actually given a scenario and some data to interact with and then is asked to produce a graphical representation of that data.
They're given freedom in how to graph it and then represent that distribution graphically.
Again, something that would be difficult to do and score in a paper pencil environment, but by introducing the functionality of the online assessment, we gained some capabilities to be able to do this.
And this item actually, the scoring for it is actually very, very complicated because the student is given so many degrees of freedom in how they can represent it.
They can do it in a way that feels right to them.
It doesn't prescribe them to have to answer the one way that we thought was right.
So as you can see, both of these items, we chose them on purpose to try to represent some of the direction that moving into an online assessment has given to do what the NGSS asks a student to do, which is clearly not simply recall information and even apply that information, but to analyze, to interpret, or to apply specific concepts in a much more interactive way.
The next slide is a little bit to just highlight.
We talked a lot about accessibility a few moments ago in the Smarter Balanced test.
During the pilot, we already have begun bringing in accessibility features.
in part to test them out and begin to identify challenges because the CAST assessment introduces item types that are not present in the SMARTER test, similar to what you just saw.
Those are new approaches to items that are specific to science and the needs of science.
So currently for the CAST pilot, we have embedded American Sign Language videos, we have refreshable braille, text-to-speech, which you saw was one of the most used accommodations within the Smarter, and print-on-demand.
Additional features will be added over time as we move forward, but these are the ones that are available for the pilot.
I believe, Michelle, you wanted to go on with the CATS science?
So now I'm going to show you a sample from the alternate assessment that we are developing that will be a part of the pilot.
The sample I'm showing you is publicly available.
Remember, the alternate assessment is for, we sometimes refer to it as our 1% test, but it's for the students with the most severe cognitive disabilities.
It is aligned via the core content connectors to NGSS.
So there is this intermediary alignment that occurs with this assessment.
Also, as a reminder, when you approved the test design for this assessment, we came to you with a very new and different type of design, and you were favorable of that.
We referred to it as an embedded performance task.
Maybe you'll understand a little bit better when you see the example, but there's been a little confusion about what does embedded mean in the field.
We probably should have used a different word now that we think about it, because we already used that word for something else.
But at the time, it made sense.
So the example in the pilot that we'll be doing this year doesn't fully utilize the embedded aspect of that.
Because in the future, we will have more flexibility in when the performance tests are given.
So in other words, they can embed them or schedule them around when that content is being taught.
in their class that allows them to utilize the information that they gain from this assessment to reteach, if necessary, the content that is being assessed in the items.
That is what is meant by the word embedded.
Embedded within an instructional cycle.
So let's go through the sample here.
It takes more slides than probably it needs to be.
But the sample you'll see here, it has the performance expectation.
This performance expectation has to do with observations and identifying materials based on their properties.
Then you'll see the core content connector.
In this case, it's classifying through observation materials.
You'll see an EG there, which is very important as you see the item.
And it gives you examples about what those observations might be.
You'll see here shape, texture, color, and so forth.
And those are by physical properties.
You'll also see here focal knowledge, skills, and abilities as it relates to this performance expectation as well as essential understanding.
So if you look at this sample, which is currently posted now, the one sample, you'll see that what we tried to do was find that sweet spot, if you will, between standardization and flexibility so that we give our educators as much flexibility as we can to make sure they are getting from their students a measure of all that that student knows and understands.
So in this case, you'll see from the checklist of physical properties, because it is about physical properties, you'll see a list of physical properties there, such as clear, opaque, hard, soft, sink, float, lots of options.
Because if you think back to what we are measuring, it wasn't, do they understand sink, float, for example.
It was, can they classify by a physical property?
So now we are allowing some flexibility in terms of the specific physical property that is being assessed.
So there are options here.
It isn't completely open-ended.
We wanted to make sure that all the options were appropriate in terms of being a physical property that is related to the NGSS to science.
Then you'll see next to it a set of materials.
Next to some of the physical properties, they have an asterisk.
If you use the asterisk and follow it through, that is completely provided for you in this embedded performance task.
All the materials are there.
You can completely follow that through.
But you could also select something that doesn't have an asterisk.
Let's say you select something like Sync Float, but then you also select Solid Liquid.
Solid Liquid does not have an asterisk.
So when I go over to the materials, I can see if I selected Sink Float, I could use materials in this embedded performance task that later I will have images for.
That cotton ball, coin, that I could use to measure whether or not they sink or float.
I could also come up with my own set of materials to measure sink float.
I don't really care what the materials are.
It's not important to whether or not you understand sink float.
If you have some type of materials that you're using every day in the classroom, manipulatives with this population, write those down.
We give you a box there to tell us what those are.
We no longer say, go collect a coin, go collect a cotton ball.
We also have provided some more flexibility in terms of what the teacher actually says.
We used to have very specific say this boxes.
And we've heard from our teachers that sometimes they use specific terminology to get concepts across, and they would like a little more flexibility in that.
So we do provide for them an exemplar of introduction.
But they don't specifically have to use that.
They can use something else.
But again, they would have to tell us what it is that they are providing.
Then you'll see here the list of materials.
So we do want to make sure that if a school or district does not want to collect their own materials, that they do have an option that makes it all the way through the process.
They can use these images.
They can use the physical properties that have the asterisks next to it, if you will.
And they could print this out or show it on a screen, whichever is best for that student, in order to measure whether or not they can classify objects into these categories.
This is how they could capture.
They could circle, for example, hard soft.
They could point to it.
Again, complete flexibility in how you would gather a student response.
But what is not flexible is the scoring rubric.
So you'll see a very specific scoring rubric associated with this task.
You'll see that here.
Again, this is scored by the teacher as he or she
administers the performance task, which is a one-on-one administration.
I want to point that out because there has also been some confusion on that in the field.
So you'll see here the rubric, which for this item is also posted as an example.
So we will be providing the pilot.
The pilot will include a performance task for each of the grades that we are measuring for this year.
What's important about the pilot this year is not so much how the students scored, but really hearing from our educators about their experience in administering this type of assessment, as well as hearing from students themselves who will also have a very short survey that they answer to let us know how they felt, were they frustrated or not, and so forth.
So they will also be given an opportunity to provide us that information.
So I was going to keep going with the idea you would ask questions at the end.
Is that OK?
Yeah, go ahead.
So the next part is I wanted to let you know about the CASP Institutes.
And I couldn't help but show off tweets.
So you will see them here because I was excited.
And I really don't know Twitter that much.
But someone told me the hashtag to put in.
So you can also go put the hashtag CASP Institute in.
And I think you'll see some very positive feedback from those who attended the CASP Institutes this year.
So, a reminder, this is very unique.
This is something that I'm sure other Smarter Balanced States would like to do, but we're the only ones that I know of that are doing a two-day workshop on not only how do you go in and give a test, it's not about that at all.
It's about using the comprehensive assessment system.
And it's not necessarily for our testing directors, again.
They are bringing with them
curriculum leaders.
I sat at a table where we had a teacher there with her principal and the conversations that they were having.
They weren't the testing individuals at that school.
So this is an opportunity for those.
And I hope that you all champion this training and get as many people signed up as you can.
But this year, we trained 1,400 educators in California.
I would love to do more, but I am out of money.
So did you read what she said?
Well, this is actually from a trainer.
What does it look like when 300 educators reflect on assessment best practice?
That's what that one says.
So in the training this year, we did a slightly different approach.
We had breakout sessions this year.
We had sessions such as designate supports for English learners and accommodations.
And this is a slide that we got, you know, everyone loved this slide.
Loved this visual about equity, equality versus equity, states exactly why equity is so important.
So, nice conversations occurring in the room regarding that.
We had a session about interim assessment.
We had a session about our teacher guides.
We had a session that looked at a balanced assessment system and what does that mean locally?
and questioning, what are the assessments that you're giving locally, and what is their purpose?
And not everyone could answer that.
Sometimes the purpose was, well, that's what we give every year.
And so it was a great conversation for them to think, why do I give that NWEA every year?
So that was interesting.
Here's some more comments.
Assessment is not just about mining data, but instruction and getting the best use out of assessments.
I thought that was a good one.
Gained exciting new tools to use at the second day, a must for fostering more ownership of the formative assessment idea.
I love the word ownership.
Providing ELs equal access to educational opportunities is a legal and moral imperative.
So these are the kinds of comments that we got, not from trainers, but from actual attendees at the workshop.
I already mentioned that one.
So the next thing I wanted to point your attention to is we did implement the self-registration for the digital library.
So that means that educators in California do not need to rely on their district CASP coordinator to sign them up for a digital library account.
We did have one board member who really championed this idea.
I'm sure you can guess who that was.
So we implemented that, and I think we've had about 3,000 new accounts for the digital library.
And we continue to improve upon the digital library and make enhancements.
One of the enhancements we made recently, which
seems trivial, but actually is a great idea.
You just have to log on to the digital library and go to your account to find out what's new in those areas that I've already identified as important to me.
And now you have a way of getting those in your email.
To remind you, you have this resource, and guess what?
A new digital library resource in that area that you've already identified as something you're interested in has recently been posted.
Go check it out.
So now we can drive traffic back to the digital library.
It's not just, you know, log in once.
But you know when new things have been loaded.
And that's it.
That's long enough.
Yeah.
Okay.
So now board member comments.
I'm going to go back to science.
The whole thing was impressive and fun, but on science, you made a comment that something like
Or maybe it was your friend in the audience made a comment that something like the NGSS are so different from previous science standards that they have posed much more of a challenge in terms of how to construct the items.
And I'm assuming that that has something to do with the
the bundling of the cross-cutting concepts, disciplinary core ideas and practices, and desire to do that as often as possible.
So that's one of my questions.
And the other was that you said that you met recently with Pellegrino and all of those guys that have done science assessments at the national and international level.
and that, I'm paraphrasing, but you prefaced it by saying we've had some challenges, we have some things we need to improve, and so I'm curious about what you showed us in terms of those test items, and whether or not those were some of the items that that group of experts responded to and made suggestions around, or whether it was something else.
That was about five questions.
I will try and answer and make sure you can correct me if I didn't capture it all.
Yes, it is the three-dimensional aspect to NGSS that causes a challenge.
I think that when we started, we provided a test design to you.
We made a commitment that each item would align to two of three dimensions.
And we are committed to that promise, that board action, and we believe that we can deliver on that.
But we may have to modify slightly how we go about that, for example.
We've really thought more and had conversations about the science and engineering practices and how they fit in and how they really are the integral part of making sure that the item comes across as NGSS-like, if you will.
And it is the practice that is almost the key to making sure that when we have that,
two-dimensional science and engineering is there along with the DCI.
So as part of the conversation that we had, the items that we showed to you, the two samples that we showed, we did get very specific feedback on the sample items that we have posted from the experts.
And this wasn't the first time they've seen it.
We've actually been very open with our items, with the individuals that we've mentioned, and we've received feedback all along in terms of our item development.
In terms of the items on the training test, we are looking at making modifications to them, partly so that they're more like what we're writing now.
The items that you see posted are what I refer to as first generation NGSS items.
And I think not only the experts, but our actual item writers at ETS have learned quite a bit as we've been talking to educators, as we've been writing items aligned to these standards.
And the items that we're writing are, I think, more aligned to those science and engineering practices than maybe what you see displayed in that training test.
So we do plan on going back to the items that we have publicly posted and making modifications to those based on specific feedback that we got from the experts.
And remember, someone's there, so she can comment on this.
But I believe that everyone in the room was very positive.
The feedback that we got was constructive and very specific in nature, if you will.
They were things we could walk away and go back and change.
And I'm just imagining not having been there nor having ever written science items, but having been in NGSS, you know, from the 2011 on the board.
that one of the things that I could imagine you doing with some of those items, they looked really complex, and especially in terms of the amount of text that were on them.
And I can imagine that one of the things that you might be trying to do is keep the integrity and the idea of having at least two out of three of the concepts together, but looking for ways to
It's like improving an essay in a sense.
Could we say this with fewer words?
Could we say it with more clear words?
That was specific feedback was on the reading load of the items was specific feedback that we did receive.
So we'll be looking at that.
I think there's a balance because with science, you automatically reduce some of that reading load sometimes by adding images.
And then we have a different problem, which is accessibility for low vision and blind students.
So it isn't an easy solution, but it is something that we received feedback on that we're going back and looking at.
Yeah, and just a couple of comments on that.
Definitely the level of detail that some of these experts have in really looking into these specific questions and wording and all that.
Coming up just with agreement on terminology, what is an item?
Is an item this many pieces or is an item one question?
So all of that was just fascinating to watch.
So I feel really good about the folks who are involved in this design.
The other considerations too was how long this test will end up being and are you able to get the breadth and the depth and all of that.
So all those technical pieces are definitely being worked out.
Okay.
Other comments?
Board Member Strauss.
Well, Michelle, I just want to thank you for the update.
I thought it was really thorough.
It really helps us know where we're going and just makes me think about the huge tasks that you've all undertaken and where we are along the process.
I think I'll be really interested to hear the sense of the feedback on the pilot test.
I know it's a complicated process and I know it's been a challenge to put these items together.
And I guess my question is, having worked in schools for so long,
When I asked you what levels these are, these are challenging.
So I think just the training for the teachers who have to prepare their kids before they take the exam and whether they have enough materials and practice materials enough, because it's going to be a real change from what they've been used to, as you showed us by the example of the old CST and the new assessment.
Again, I'll be interested in the update.
I really appreciate the time you took to walk us through and also the accommodation information about how people are accessing that I think is actually very helpful to us.
So I just appreciate the and I'll look forward to continued updates.
Thank you.
and then the superintendent michelle michelle i also want to thank you for preparing this update it's i always look forward to hearing from you particularly to hear about the ongoing development and blossoming of the casp system i think that the work that's been undertaken by this state that began with ab484 that
completely scrapped and charged the board with leading the work to implement a new assessment system in the state has been marked by a lot of very strong adjectives, creative, thoughtful, innovative, but what has really impressed me about the work the department has undertaken is that you have been so thorough
and thinking through what is required to do this work and taking the time to lay out an architecture that from top to bottom, the bottom being the district, not the student, that it considers what the differences in the implementation issues would be and making very personal and direct contacts with districts to help them.
At any point in time, something could have gone terribly wrong.
And while those things went terribly wrong in other states, it did not here in a state that tested a significantly larger number of students.
So the fact that that work has been undertaken is important.
But it wasn't just the work to implement the system.
It's all the other multiple pieces that were being invented and implemented at the same time.
So I, even though my head spins every time I hear all of the work that's being undertaken, I always remain impressed.
I am so thankful for your patience, personally, because I was very dogged and determined about the implementation of the digital library and about that access because it's free.
And for some reason, that just seemed to escape people that this was a valuable tool that was not being used as well as it could have been.
So I really appreciate the diligent effort that the department has made to try to create better accessibility.
What I'm going forward, what I truly look forward to is as we complete all the parts of the picture and some of those parts are coming in to development sooner rather than later.
that we also have the opportunity to take a look at what has resulted as a result of these changes.
Because I'm still seeing the same bad behaviors as the system is being implemented.
I'm still seeing, even though the clear purposes, for example, of the interim assessments are to allow options to embed the assessments, they're not being used that way, and they're being abused in ways that they weren't intended for.
So I'm hoping as the system continues to mature,
that there's more attention being paid to what you're actually telling staff and district personnel about good and appropriate and really improved practices for using the tools that are being made available to them.
They're not just simply putting down one tool and filling in the blank with a new tool and abusing it in an inappropriate way.
So, I'm hoping that as we mature the system, that we also mature our understanding about how to use all these tools well.
Okay, any further discussion after the superintendent will speak first.
Well thanks, everybody's been expressing exciting great progress and I think as I go around the state I see teachers very eager to get into this to understand how they can best help students and use the data to inform instruction.
You mentioned how, you know, 1,400 came for your two-day institute and that's fabulous.
I'm also thinking it's a daunting challenge to reach out to 330,000 teachers and looking at the vast size of our school system.
And wouldn't you like to have more?
You ran out of money.
Wouldn't you like to do five institutes?
So I've just raised a question because when we started five years ago, we looked to get extra help.
We got the legislature to do $1.4 billion.
And that bought internet connectivity, internet connecting devices, capacity bandwidth, and professional development, heavily used.
Not too much on curricular materials.
So I'm just thinking, are there some things that we should inventory where we're at?
And I will go back.
In my department, we have an education technology task force report, and we're going to update it.
How many schools are one-to-one?
How many schools have access to the computer lab?
What should be done about it?
The digital divide is still enormous, I think.
So how do we have more access to it, not just for test-taking, interim test-taking, but for instruction and learning on an ongoing basis?
So I just raised a question, are there some things too that we should be advising or communicating to districts so that in their LCAP process they look at what are the needs?
Are they short on computers?
Is somebody raising that?
are the individuals who came, the teachers who came to your institute going back and lobbying for more in the LCAP for what's needed.
And then collectively, besides the local emphasis we've transitioned into, still the legislature has put money aside at different times to help us invest in closing the gaps on internet connectivity.
And should we do some more of that?
And I think we should.
So I just raised the questions and perhaps.
Mr. President, come back with an item in either May or later at the next meeting on what we do know.
What's the updated survey and information on the computer capacity and how big of a gap do we still have to overcome?
All right.
I think we're ready for a break.
And so the board will reconvene at 20 of 11.
50 to 49.
So they were repealed, one vote.
Alright, we're ready for the item.
Item 7.
Non-classroom charters.
Good morning again.
This is Cindy Chan, Director of the Charter Schools Division at the California Department of Education.
I have to ask you guys to put not just your charter hat on, but your fiscal hat.
I'm so excited to present a funding determination.
I could spend hours up here, but I will try to keep it brief.
Item 7 is a request for a retroactive determination of funding for River Valley Charter, a non-classroom based charter school.
This request is one we would call non-recurring.
It's not one that is brought to you on most of your agendas.
And it includes three main elements, the funding determination and years, which you must approve, consider, and approve.
The mitigating circumstances is the second piece.
And then the fact that this one is retroactive.
So I will try to briefly walk through the determination of funding, the mitigating circumstances, and then the school's actual request.
So the determination of funding contains two components that you have to consider.
So I'm going to kind of give you some buzzwords to keep in mind.
The funding determination, think of that as the how much.
So it's a percentage or rate that drives, that's applied to the charter school's ADA, non-classroom based ADA, determines how much money they're going to get.
The second piece is the effective period, the how long.
So this is what you approve for the number of years or the term of the funding determination.
The law has limits.
There's a floor, a minimum of two years and a maximum of five years that you can approve.
The criteria for offending determination, it's pretty much all based on how much the school spends.
There's four that are in law, four rates or percentages, 100, 85, 70, and then there's a denial of offending determination that ends up being zero.
The rate or percentage is based on three criteria that the charter school must meet.
Two of these are based on how much is spent for instruction, and this is really important for this one because the school did not meet this criteria.
So for full funding, for 100%, the charter school has to spend at least 40% or more of its total public revenues on certificated employee salaries and benefits.
And second, it has to spend at least 80% or more of its total revenues on instruction or instruction-related services.
And then third, for full funding, the charter school's people-to-teacher ratio must be less than 25 to 1.
The second area I want to talk about that is part of the school's request is mitigating circumstances.
So if a charter school underspends, the regulations provide some discretion for the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools and the State Board to consider and make a recommendation for either a higher or even a lower rate.
if so warrants, provided that it finds a reasonable basis to do so.
So they have to provide, you can't just approve it.
There has to be a rationale, a reason to provide something other than what the statute or the regulations would normally allow.
We refer to this as a mitigating circumstance.
The regulations provide specific examples that are in the item of types of mitigating circumstances that can be used as a guide and can be considered they're all fiscal with the exception of a couple to do with size and newness of a charter school.
And keep in mind that the intent of the mitigating circumstance, kind of like a waiver, non-permanent waiver, it should be temporary.
It should be one time.
It should be something that's not ongoing.
Otherwise, it'd be like a permanent waiver of the required provisions of this statute.
The Charter School provides its individual mediating circumstance in support of why it underspent on instruction.
And I want to kind of bring in one piece here because there was a discussion at the Advisory Commission and it comes up quite a bit and don't hate me when I talk about people achievement here but
It's really not part of this process and it's not one of the examples that's provided as mitigating circumstances.
This process is fiscally driven.
It's focused on how much the charter school spent on instruction.
The legislature included only one element of academic achievement and it was API ranking that's in the statute.
And it's used as, so to speak, a reward for high-performing charter schools, but it's only used to allow for the how long, the years.
It doesn't affect the how much, the rate.
And then further, the ACCS was charged with developing the regulations that it follows and that the State Board follows, and nowhere does it include academic achievement, with the exception of this carve-out for virtual schools that is usually not ever used.
So the Advisory Commission met on February 13th and voted to approve the mitigating circumstances request and determination of funding for 100% for two years, 2016-17 and the next fiscal year, 17-18.
The vote was 5-3.
And then now River Valley Charter's request.
Let me just kind of go through that for you for what is included in what they provided to the advisory commission.
The request is retroactive due to the school submitting to the department late.
It needed an approved state board waiver.
It received one at your November 16, 2016 meeting.
The data included in the funding determination request is based on 2014-15 because it's retroactive late kind of goes back
Sometime it's not as current as others you would normally see.
The school for that year in question spent, kind of keep in mind, the floor for certificated staff is 40.
The school spent at 56, so it didn't meet that requirement.
However, on instruction, the floor being at 80, the school spent at 71, so very much on the low end.
It actually almost dipped into the next lower funding band, barely made it by about 1.85%.
Because it underspent on that second criteria, it by law would receive an 85% determination of funding or percentage.
The school's mitigating circumstances include that the school had a new principal with no charter experience and wasn't aware of the spending requirements.
The school delayed the purchase of new textbooks and supplies for classes that were not yet Common Core aligned with the exclusion of English language arts and mathematics.
And the school chose to instead increase their reserves.
So in our analysis and our support for the recommendation, we just want to point out that River Valley Charter was one of the very first schools approved for a funding determination in 2001.
In total, the school has requested and received five prior funding determinations.
And so we find that because of their long history with this process and the fact that they should have known the requirements, that really we didn't find that as a mitigating reason for the school's underspending.
And secondly, the school ended 14-15 with a 42% reserve of approximately $800,000 to $900,000.
A minimal portion of those reserves could have been used to support instruction for the students rather than to save for savings.
If they had only spent $163,000 of those reserves, the reserve balance would still have remained high.
They would have still had around $700,000.
that wasn't a reason for mitigating circumstance.
Based on that, we recommend that the state board deny the mitigating circumstances request and approve 85% for the minimum of two years would be the current year and next fiscal year.
So I can answer any questions that you may have.
I'm not sure if the school's here.
They might be here for comment.
Okay, liaison wanna comment on this first?
Do we know if the school's here?
Nobody's raising their hand.
So this particular ACCS meeting, there were only four items on the agenda.
They were all funding determinations, so a decision was made to make it a teleconference meeting.
And so there were a few, Brian Bauer and a few people actually in the room, and then there were people at their homes and offices.
And I don't know about everybody else that was at their home or office, but I could get none of the live streaming video.
So I got it up, but it froze.
It would not continue to go.
So all I heard was voices and no one identified their names.
And so it was a little bit, you know, it wasn't as thorough for me as most of these are.
However, the the current principle, the new principle of
River Valley is in San Diego.
And so she was sitting next to me in my living room.
And she also was listening to Faceless Voices discussing her charter school.
So I cannot remember how long the new principal has been there and how long the previous principal that did not
who has been used as the reason for the mitigating circumstances how long she was at the school.
Do you know that?
No, it was, I mean, the 14, 2014-15 was the year of the former principal, and then there was a transition between, I don't, I'm not sure when the old one left for 15-16, so I'm not sure about that middle year.
I don't, that information wasn't provided, so we didn't know.
Okay.
Further, it was just an unusual split of the, of the ACCS in terms of the five and three.
It's not a split that we see that often, so,
I just share that as some background for not finding this as straightforward as some of them are for me and I'll let other board members ask questions and make comments.
I have a question about the reserve.
You said that they had a 42% reserve.
What is common practice for reserves for charter schools?
There's no, some of you can correct me if I'm wrong, there's no required minimum.
I mean, for our state board charter schools, we require 5%.
So and that's based on the memorandum of understanding.
Other charter schools, I don't know.
Classroom-based charter schools tend to have a higher reserve.
They've kind of stated that at some of the meetings.
And I just want to say we were in the past before LCFF during deficit factor and deferrals.
I think we were more flexible on allowing for those reserves.
In some of the items we've seen that we've brought forward, even the ACCS is, okay, we're kind of beyond those years.
And so there's been a mix of votes in the past.
Departments are usually pretty consistent.
In this case, it's fairly high.
And so we kind of made a recommendation similar to we have other schools that have had reserves in the close to 50% range.
Okay.
Eileen, I thought you were next.
You're going to go after Bruce.
Okay.
Hi, Cindy.
Hi.
So there was no one representing the school in the room?
Sounds like no one signed up.
I apologize, but I have to ask you the question.
Sure.
So they did not, in the waiver application, specify specifically why they had 842 percent, 800,000 in reserve.
You indicated that they had delayed textbook purchase or something that contributed to that, right?
But at the same time, there wasn't a specific reason like we are saving to buy a building or our lease is going to triple, you know, those sorts of things.
I can look.
I mean, the main reason was, I think what they tried to provide was what we could have spent that would have counted toward instruction were the textbooks, but we delayed that.
I don't believe there was anything else other than I think, you know, they did want to save for an economic uncertainty, but they had quite a bit set aside for that.
I can look at the request one more time to see, but I don't remember facilities being part of that.
Because that's usually a common one, and they end up having to save more when they're saving for facilities.
And actually, there is, when we look at the breakdown of reserves, there is one that they would set aside for facilities acquisition or capital projects, and that one is zero.
So what they're showing in reserves is a half a million for economic uncertainties and unassigned.
So it's just sort of an appropriated fund balance.
So it's like nothing specific.
Okay, Board Member Strauss.
I guess I want to build and kind of continue on what Board Member Holladay is asking.
So, I know a lot of districts and LEAs have delayed purchasing of the LAELD materials, but not necessarily, well, MAF and ELD, but they still need to have some materials.
It's a huge reserve for me.
And I guess the concern I have is if the organization has been in operation for as long as it has,
Did they base their reason for the larger reserve only on the lack, the delay of textbook purchases?
That was all, and no dollar amount, so it was really hard for us to know how much that would have been.
And again, it wasn't, based on that, it wasn't for ELA and math, so it, I'm not an expert, it's for the other remaining Common Core aligned materials.
I don't know how much that would be.
I would think that would be the lesser amount, but I don't know that.
That part I'm not certain.
And then I guess to clarify back, I know you were on the phone and it was hard to hear.
So the reason you had a split vote and it seems like the CDE had good justification for 85% and the committee voted over majority to support the 100%.
Yes, that's correct.
I think there was
You know, very few charter issues are cut and dried.
I think there was sympathy on the part of the five that voted in favor of 100% that.
that there had been a new principal that had never operated a charter school before.
And while you can make the case for where was the board, was all the board there, was there a financial officer there, you can certainly make that case.
But there was some sympathy to the fact they've evidently removed that principal.
And the one sitting next to me was the new principal, as I understand it.
And the impression that I have, and even though
Even though school performance is not a criteria, they are a high-performing school.
So I think they've done well on other kinds of things.
And I think my impression was that the new principal that had never been a charter operator before messed up.
and that the amount of money that ended up in reserve was not intentional.
I don't remember hearing anything about we decided to, you know, increase our reserve.
I think it was because money wasn't spent in the one place.
It wound up in their savings account.
That's what I think.
So, you know, there's, frankly, there's an argument to be based, you know, on both sides of this.
But five of the eight did vote.
to go with 100 percent, including we did get public testimony from people that argued for the 100 percent, even from the school district.
Yeah, are we getting ready for a motion here?
Just real quickly, I thought, so isn't this school tied to its district?
It's, it's, is it direct funded, locally funded?
There was a district union representative that supported it.
CTA.
Yes, actually, CTA spoke in support, which is usually a little different.
Kind of what I remember of this chart.
I don't have the fun type here.
I think it is because there was, I think in our kind of question and answer with the school, I think the district is somehow always included.
So there is a little more interaction with the district.
Most of the requests we get is very much removed.
Schools are more autonomous.
And the reason I ask that is because if it is, from what I remember, I remember that this school may have had a closer relationship with its district.
And sometimes, so I can understand a brand new principal, if the district was, if it's in the district budget, the district tended to manage it a little bit more, a brand new person coming in may not have been, had the wherewithal to really understand.
I think, you know, I don't want to over-aggress this because it's really up to the charter school to provide their reasons for why they want the 100% determination.
I actually just had more of a side comment.
I know that we've had these regs, SB 740 regs, for a very long time.
And I know that there's been some discussion about re-looking at that.
And I think when we go with these straight formulas, we run into issues.
So I would just encourage us to look into this whole 740 regulations and taking a look at that with our charter school stakeholders.
So that's just a side.
Board Member Burrough.
Yes.
Well, Board Member Sun took the words right out of my mouth that these regulations existed way before we had local control funding formula.
And for us to be micromanaging how charter schools are spending their money is just wrong in my view.
So I think that we should adhere to what our advisory commission recommended.
And I think that we should re-examine the regulations and whether we even need to have them.
Yeah, we need to find out what the statute is, but that's not for today.
Okay.
So we have a motion.
Not yet.
Yeah, we don't have a motion, but we got a public comment.
No public comment.
Ortiz-Lacombe.
I'm not aware of what regulations you're referring to and I think that if that's going to help streamline this process, that's amazing.
We should really revisit that.
However, I am troubled by the fact that the school did not show up because I would want to hear some of the questions that we have and that we're anticipating with their reasoning.
I don't want to anticipate, I want to hear it from them.
I was in preview to the previous meeting in the discussion of whether to this recommendation.
And I think that it's fair for us to ask them directly.
So the fact that they didn't show up gives me a little pause because maybe they feel like they don't have to justify why they want their 100%.
But with the reserve that they have, you know, and yes, it is a new principle, but then that principle should have been mentored by an organization that has done this several times, several years.
So I'm just, that gives me a little bit of concern that they didn't show up to explain their side.
And just to add a little bit of the discussion, I'm not sure if you, because both of you were remote.
We did talk about the fact that there is an area, there's a provision in the regulations that allows the school to come back to the commission and show that based on, it'd be the same funding determination.
Let's just say you approve something lower.
The regulations allow the school to come back and show, well, in the following fiscal year, I actually spent where I should have been.
It was a blip.
And that's happened in the past, and the commission has approved something higher, and it replaces the funding determination in effect.
So there is another opportunity, because I know it's always hard to recommend something where a school's going to lose money.
But that's what the regulations allow, and because this is retroactive, the school could come back almost immediately, and we would look at
New information would be another year of data now if the school showed it underspent two years in a row That's a little more compelling for the Commission to think like, you know, you're not taking this serious You've you've already approved by the state board to spend 100% in that year and you didn't do it but there is an opportunity for them to do so and We would work with the school in that so that's just more information that we talked about at the meeting Okay
Cindy, I appreciate and I thank you for the detailed information.
I too am troubled by the fact that the school did not come.
Just as an aside, I would like to say I would like a job where I am in charge, I get paid a whole lot of money,
and I don't know how to do anything.
I do agree that this school, having been in place since 2001, there seems to be some momentum or some automaticity about the work that is done for managing both the program and the fiscal requirements that need to be in place.
to operate the school.
So I am concerned that this is an important fiscal decision that rests on some very specific parameters for approving it at these different levels.
I'm glad to know that there's this strong relationship that the LEA has with the charter and that all these stakeholders feel that there's a need to
look at the criteria concerning funding the school in this way.
But there are, even though we're saying we don't want to make any suppositions about what else happened at the school, we are making suppositions about what else happened at this school and what those mitigating factors actually mean.
And so I'm uncomfortable with that.
One of my assumptions is that if the administrator was appointed, the administrator knew what was going to be the obligations and responsibilities of the work that was being taken on.
And if it wasn't done well, I'm glad to know the charter took action to remove that administrator.
but I don't have the luxury of knowing what else has been done since then to fix or address all of those other factors.
So I'm uncomfortable with making some assumptions that something's been done and I don't know, the school is not here to tell me, having corrected the leadership issue, that the other factors then have actually been addressed or are underway of being addressed.
So I'm very, very uncomfortable with the higher determination.
Yeah, we're ready for a motion.
I am a little bit more cautious than Member Burr.
These non-classroom charters, they can run with very little personnel, very little contact.
This is a pretty gray area of the charters and
For the board to say, you know, it's just hands off on non-classroom charters, I'm reluctant.
You're going to have to convince me more that there is so much quality here and uniformity that there's no need to be concerned about these issues with non-classroom based charters.
That's just a caution that when we get into this as a policy, I think we need to deliberate carefully.
I would agree with her on charters that have actually some classrooms and meet directly with pupils.
I would say, President Kirst, that we have classroom-based charters and non-charter schools that are not performing as they should be either.
So I'm not sure it's necessarily the non-classroom-based piece of things as well.
Well, if you look at the studies by the Credo group at Stanford, you will see a really different picture on achievement scores for non-classroom based charters in some cases.
So, yeah.
And the other thing about the regulations is that the definition of a non-classroom-based charter school has gotten fuzzier and fuzzier over the years because there are all sorts of various types, blended learning types and all the rest.
So it's very difficult to have a one-size-fits-all in these situations.
But that's not the matter with this charter.
No, I was just commenting about that.
I reluctantly introduced broader issues, but I did want to concern.
Yeah, I think we're ready for the motion.
We need some public comment.
Well, there's discomfort all the way around.
It appears we've had a long day and a half.
Do you know whether or not they have classrooms and resource centers?
I'm assuming that they do.
There was an implication here that it almost said it was a virtual school, and I'm almost certain that's not the case.
But I did look at their attendance, and it's 100% non-classroom.
You know, sometimes there is a blend, so a charter school might have both a portion of classroom-based.
This one is reporting as if it's 100% non-classroom-based.
And would that mean they wouldn't have resource centers or not?
No, no, we just wouldn't see that.
That's not part of a data sort of reporting, and it's not part of the form, so we don't know that.
Okay.
Well, I do know that based on statewide ranks on test scores that there are 10.
So they're doing well.
I know that's not a part of the criteria, but it's a part of it.
Then we're going to get into whether this is CST or Smarter Balanced.
You can't get away with that without...
I don't I don't think we should introduce this because if any of that's on Smarter Balanced and and excuse me But the only reason I'm bringing it up is because you mentioned the credo study and that had to do primarily with virtual Open the door.
Yeah, I was applied to a specific thing.
Yeah, I
Okay, back to this.
Back to this one.
Okay, I am knowing that there is various levels of discomfort all around.
I am persuaded by the ACCS 5-3 vote and the fact that maybe I had the opportunity to meet the current executive director and feel like
that kind of thing is possible.
It's not like it's never happened in a traditional school, that you get a new principal or a new director and some things kind of slip for a while.
And I would be more inclined to go with the five to three vote of the ACCS, support that, as opposed to hoping that we have them on another agenda item in the next year.
So you recommend... 100 percent two years.
Okay, that's... Okay, is there a second to that?
Okay, public comment.
Ran over here twice today.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
This school is not one of our clients, and I don't know it well.
I did want to speak to some of these issues with respect to reserve levels.
The regulations here effectively cap schools at a 5% reserve, which for a non-classroom-based school is way too low, given all of the volatility that they usually face.
It's an unusually competitive sector.
Huge chunks of parents and students can move overnight.
And so, in an ideal world, we would like to see charter schools of this sort with reserves at the level where they're currently at.
With respect to is this an unregulated sector, it is definitely the single most highly regulated sector in all of California public education school district or charter.
There are, you have to meet a 25 to 1 student to teacher ratio, all kinds of other things that load up costs, plus there's intense paperwork behind it.
It's definitely the most regulated.
Most important, the regulations here are way outdated.
In fact, they don't allow you to cut their funding.
It speaks to the old revenue limit system, and the statutes have not been updated to do that.
So we really need to take a new look at these regulations and fix them.
Thank you.
Clarifying question on the motion.
Cindy, so when I'm reading the summary, they have had five funding terminations before this one.
Is that correct?
And has it always been at 100 percent?
Not the first one.
But I think the first one was that I think no one got 100 percent on the first one.
It was the way the regulations were written.
All the other ones were 100 percent.
Yes.
The very first one was 95 percent.
And then every one after that, the next four were at 100.
All right.
Moved and seconded.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
So... Okay.
And vote.
No votes?
Are you a no vote?
All right.
Yes vote.
So we have six votes.
OK.
So the motion passes as is with six votes.
Yeah.
Motion for 100 percent.
We had a motion on 100 percent.
That's what we voted on.
OK.
Now we're on to the consent calendar first.
The waivers we will take up first.
All these are on proposed consent waivers W through 12.
And we have one recruitment by board member Strauss on waivers.
One through 11.
I move the consent items.
One through 11, not one through 12.
Any public comment on these?
All right.
Not all those in favor, raise your hand.
No.
Waiver 12 is... Waiver 12?
Eileen comes back.
Waiver 12.
Oh, Eileen comes back.
Okay.
Yeah, that's it.
It's still on consent, but you can participate.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I'm ready for a motion on consent calendar for Waiver 12.
Do we have any comment on Waiver 12?
I think we do.
We have a comment for Waiver 4.
Oh, oh.
And we have a comment for Waiver 12.
OK, so wait, let's do Waiver 4.
Let's come up on Waiver 4.
So on Waiver 4, we have Dr. Janie Iden and Colette Eichenbinder.
My name is Dr. Janie Iden.
This is Ms.
Colette Finkbeiner.
I'm the director of Twin Ridges Home Study Charter School, and Ms.
Finkbeiner is our business manager.
We came here just to briefly comment on waiver number four.
We just wanted to let you know that this was a temporary request.
We had a teacher resign at the beginning of the school year, leaving 25 students without a credentialed teacher.
In order to accommodate these students, we asked our full-time teachers to take on 27 students so that we could serve all of the students without a teacher.
This was temporary.
We were able to hire a full-time credentialed teacher within a month.
So at this moment, everything is as usual, one teacher for 25 students.
Thank you.
We just really wanted to put a face to the school and let you know that as an independent study charter school, we don't have a bargaining unit, so we couldn't use other means to remedy the pupil-teacher ratio.
So that's why we're asking for this, so that we can be in compliance with the law.
And thank you for your time.
Okay, W-12.
Good morning, Ron Hacker, assistant superintendent for Centennial Valley Union High School District, speaking today in support of item W12.
Proud to support the will of the region's voters who authorized the bonds back in November with more than 80% passage rate.
And pleased to report today that the JPA's member districts are in alignment and fully support the waiver.
And I'm here if you have any questions.
Okay, do we have a motion on waiver 12?
I move the consent calendar.
Any board discussion?
Hearing none, raise your hands for that.
Okay.
This is W-12, he meant W-12.
Yeah, didn't I say W-12?
He said consent.
Oh, he said W-12 on the consent calendar.
Okay, W-12.
Let's do it again just to be clear.
What was your motion?
I moved the consent calendar.
That's different than Waiver 12.
We're on Waiver 12 right now.
Oh, I'm sorry, it was 7.
I forgot.
I move staff recommendation on waiver 12.
All right.
We have a second.
Thank you.
OK.
Now we have regular consent and we have items 10 through 12.
and 14 through 20 where all board members can vote.
So we need a motion on regular consent 10 to 12 and 14 through 30.
I move approval of the regular consent.
Second.
Public comment?
Public comment on these items.
Okay, so these are items 10 through 12, 14 through 20.
All those in favor?
Now we need a separate vote on the consent item 13.
We have four, three members who must recuse themselves.
We have a quorum.
Okay.
So now I need a motion on item 13.
Move the staff recommendation.
Okay, any public comment on item 13?
No.
Okay, all those in favor, raise your hand.
Okay, our colleagues may come back.
And now we're down to SBAE priorities.
Yeah.
So I have a very pleasant announcement before we begin these.
Our student board member, Olivia Sisson, has been admitted as an early admission student at Harvard University.
And that is really something.
And she will attend there.
You have accepted their offer.
Good.
OK.
The last student went to Harvard, too.
Yeah.
You guys have a little club.
OK.
So now we're ready for SVE priority.
I mean, priorities.
But the first thing is we need to adopt the minutes from the January 11-12-2017 meeting.
Do I have a motion on that?
I move adoption.
Second.
All those in favor?
Okay, the minutes are adopted.
All right, now I'm going to get down the list and sometimes if I miss one, we add some of these.
We're going to have our Joint Committee on Career Technical Education next time.
So these expand.
IQC Mathematics, Rucker, or Strauss.
So I attended the IQC meeting in January, and so I'll just give you up to date on some items.
The IQCs, so I'll just do general IQC if that's okay.
They're working on the health framework, so that's a new framework.
Again, we reconvened and we've done math, ELA, history, science, and now we're doing the health framework.
We also are in the process of a science materials review that will happen spring summer.
I mean a history social science materials review and then following that, we're looking at screening applications for review committee for science materials, which will happen the following year.
So those are sort of the key issues.
We did a really good orientation that CDE did for all the IQC, we haven't done that in a while, so that was a half day of orientation of procedures and orientation on IQC.
I did not attend the IQC meeting in January, but I have made a commitment to the department staff that I will be fully there as the board member to support the training that's going to go on for the curriculum review and that process that's going to start in April.
So I'm very, we are looking forward not only to the work, but also to continue the conversation about the development and improvement of the history, social science curriculum.
So I'm very excited to see that process get started.
Okay, IQC, English Language Arts, ELD, Strauss.
So the ELA-ELD group, collaborative group, was convened by CSESA and State Board and CDE as a collaborative meeting.
We had a meeting in January about what next steps to do after the rollouts.
We had really strong, I think, 10 really successful rollouts, but that really still is at the surface level of what we need to do to fully implement the framework.
So the group is meeting again, and credit to the whole team that continues to convene
very thoughtful representative groups of county offices and districts that are really thoughtful with what are the next strategies for ALD?
What do we need to do to continue to roll out?
So just to let the board and the community, the public know that we are continuing the work on ALD.
It's not done.
Even though we've adopted the framework and materials adoptions are going on, more training we believe is really necessary.
IQC history, social science.
There's been a lot of activity with rollouts this year, and they've been very well received as far as attendance goes, selling out, and they're more scheduled this year going into 2018.
And these one-day conferences focus on instructional shifts, updated and expanded content, aligning instruction with the English language arts and English language development framework, and inquiry-based instruction across all of the grade levels.
And there's more information on the CDE website if you'd like to know more.
And it's very encouraging to see the level of interest in improving history of social science instruction using the framework.
And these events are a collaborative effort between the State Board of Education, California Department of Education, the California County Superintendent's Educational Services Association, the California Subject Matter Projects, and the California Council for Social Studies.
Okay.
Now IQC Science Strauss.
So again, I just updated that we are going to be looking for material reviewers for science.
And we updated that process.
And I'll just add as well, since it's not listed, is that there's a concurrence commission of the subject matter projects.
And we met also in January here in Sacramento talking about the next steps for the subject matter projects to continue to support our work in the
curriculum framework and rollout.
I did particularly ask them to address the issue of the role of leaders in the curriculum adoption and support rollout since their work has been primarily with classroom teacher-based implementation.
So we did have a really strong discussion about that as well.
And Tom Adams is part of that team as well.
Okay, Advisory Committee on Special Education, Sandoval.
The Advisory Commission met a few weeks ago, February 22nd and 23rd, and in the few years that I've been the liaison, it was the most well-attended.
The focus of the very first day, the first afternoon, was special education finance.
And so there were presentations by
Paul Warren of the Public Policy Institute of California, and he outlined recommendations in the recent report on finance in California as it relates to special education.
There were also representatives from self-administrators of California presenting their recommendations in response to the language in the governor's budget that were specific to special education.
The commissioners also heard from Ian Johnson with the Department of Finance, who reviewed the governor's proposed budget with a focus on special education.
And he emphasized in his presentation the need to engage stakeholders in a conversation about special education, especially as it relates to the alignment with local control funding formula.
And he emphasized the need for greater integration, more flexibility, and a focus on student outcomes.
And towards that end, there are weekly stakeholder forums around this topic happening this month, hosted by the Department of Finance.
So after the presentations related to finance and special education, the commissioners engaged in small group breakout discussions.
And then when they returned to the large group, they recommended not rolling all special education funds into an unrestricted special education concentration grant, but keeping those funds specific to the students they're intended to serve.
And they talked about, the commissioners discussed the disparities between SELPA services and supports that they provide their member LEAs.
And while they clearly value the SELPAs as regional entities,
They want to ensure that the focus of any changes moving forward are really focused on improving student achievement.
And the commissioners acknowledge the importance of increasing accountability and transparency with special education services and supports in the state.
There was also a presentation by Shiloh Duncan-Besserill, and she's the Special Education Division's Data Administrator.
And she discussed the new federal regulations addressing the significant disproportionality in special ed.
And that was touched on very briefly yesterday, but she offered a very insightful presentation and showed the data.
And she described how this changed and how
suspensions and expulsions in particular are reported.
And what it highlighted is that there's a very high number of reported incidents among preschool, transitional, kindergarten, and kindergarten students.
It was shocking.
So she talked about that and how, just a quick snapshot, 715 incidents, 313 unique children, and that amounted to 923 missed education days.
Preschool, TK, and kindergarten.
Wow.
Yeah, that was the big wow.
And so the division is working closely with the early education division to begin to address this.
So I think this is an example of how the data can inform practice and better serve students right away.
So I'm happy that that's continuing.
to be addressed.
And clearly, part of the conversation was that teachers and administrators really need the support and professional learning in this area to address this issue.
So very full couple of days.
Yeah.
Full days meeting.
Summer School for the Arts, any update on that?
Summer School for the Arts met that same week, February 24th, and 1,745 students applied for approximately 500 slots.
This is the largest applicant pool in the school's 31-year history.
So, the fact that the school is receiving so many applications is really a result of strategic and focused outreach statewide.
So, I look forward to offering another update in a few months.
Okay, computer science.
So I want to thank AXA, who invited me and Hadi Partovi, one of the co-founders and the CEO of Code.org, the national nonprofit, to speak at the Superintendent's Symposium in Indian Wells.
On February 9th, he had a plenary keynote presentation on that Wednesday morning.
I took 10 minutes to update the room in terms of what was being planned on computer science.
and why we thought it was important, which means why I thought it was important, and then introduced Hadi.
And he spoke for an hour.
And he was really well-received.
And there were over 500, between 500 and 600 superintendents in the room.
So this was a huge opportunity for us to reach that particular very influential group on the importance of expanding and diversifying student access to computer science.
I also, if we're done with NGSS, I want to just add that I also, with Tom Adams, spoke at an NGSS, California NGSS K-8 early implementation initiative meeting, convening up in San Francisco on February 16th.
This was of the eight districts and two charter management organizations that participate in that initiative.
This was a meeting of their top people, the superintendents and assistant superintendents.
We've spoken before to the principals and that level of leadership, administrative leadership, but these were the top people and the curriculum instructors, leaders at the district or CMO, as well as the project leads for this early implementation initiative.
And it was really, really interesting to hear them talk with each other and answer questions about what they are learning.
They are now two and a half years into a four-year initiative, so they only have a year and a half left.
And they're learning a lot and doing a lot.
And each one of them developed, they filled out a sheet, like a two or three page sheet, answering questions of what they've been learning, what they've been trying, what their challenges are.
and what kind of help they would appreciate going forward, what they're most excited about, and what their teachers and their students, how they're reacting to the change in pedagogy in GSS.
And it was fascinating for me to read those.
I asked for a copy.
And Stephanie and Tom, if you want to get a copy, and Eileen, of course, I'd be happy to forward those to you.
And I have suggested to our president that it would be exciting for the whole California and the state board to hear a presentation by the early implementers sometime as soon as our agenda will allow it.
Because they have information and experience now that can be shared with the rest of California that is really just now really pushing to get started on implementing NGSS.
Now, Child Nutrition Council.
We didn't have a meeting, but I do have other special items.
I'm making up my own category.
All right.
That's fair.
So I was part of the, I'm part of the EL roadmap.
I'm a liaison to the EL roadmap.
We had a meeting a couple of weeks ago.
And so this, the roadmap,
is intended to revise the policy on English learners that was authored the last time in 1998.
So it was right after Prop 227 passed.
And now it's almost 20 years later after Prop 58 passed.
So we will be having a policy along with a vision statement and also some other materials that will be coming to the board.
But it's a great group.
It's high caliber EL experts from researchers to practitioners to other stakeholders.
I also presented last, I think it was last week, at the California Latino Legislative Caucus.
They invited me to present on Latino achievement and some of the equity focus initiatives and policies.
So I presented to, I think it was maybe 20 to 24 of the caucus members.
They're very interested in Latino achievement, obviously.
A good number of them are former teachers.
And so I would say seven that were in the group were actually former teachers.
So, education is one of their priorities, and they are excited to see how this year will unfold for Latinos in terms of our achievement, and I believe they're going to be taking some actions, but there is a firewall, so I didn't inquire.
Thank you.
Okay, CTC Strauss.
So I just want to, the CTC met when I was presenting at the state superintendent symposium.
And I just have to say, with Aida Molina, we presented on state accountability, which I'll update you on.
But I have to say, I got to sit in with Heidi Partovi during the presentation.
And it was powerful.
And it was right on.
And I think it was wonderful that member Williams was able to make that connection.
I mean, really set the clear stage for districts in our state.
And it was really a motive.
It was and he really made a clear argument.
This is not just about coding.
This is about computer science and all the rationale.
So I just would say it was a really motivating session.
I just want to say that as well.
So anyway, and the other thing is just before that I presented.
I've been presenting a lot of accountability around the state, along with some of our staff members and a new group that I presented to at Riverside County was the school counselors leadership network.
And so I focused a lot on the role of counselors, particularly in helping guide students in college and career readiness and what their course options were.
They were.
Of course, I looked up in the back of the room, there's Carl Cohen standing there watching me, so I guess he was in Riverside County, too.
But the school counselors, I think we need to really remember that they need to be part of this and help understand what all the being college and career ready means and what the pathways are.
And actually, Riverside County is going to do another symposium for a couple hours with leaders and counselors in April.
So I just think as we look to roll this out, it's not just about school principals and teachers, the people who are advising students and what courses they take make very overt or subtle statements that help guide students.
And I think we, I really appreciated Riverside County reaching out.
So anyway, CTC did meet, they're working a lot on the teacher shortage.
There's been a lot of research by Dr. Linda Darling-Hammond, who's chair of CTC, and they've been doing lots of hearings about that.
And also there was a recent publication also about leader shortage and what those issues are.
They've really been involved in a data dashboard that's quite extensive, and it really is a good model for showing where their students come from and what the opportunities are.
They spent a lot of time working on child development permits, so you're hearing a lot more about preschool now and what to do before students hit kindergarten.
And they're also looking at undergraduate teacher preparation programs, because under the old law,
You had to wait till your first year of graduate school to do teacher preparation.
And there's a push now to say maybe in the junior and senior year of undergrad, we could help students begin to think about being in the teacher workforce.
They had a really good study session on the credentialing issues around
career and technical education, which is something we're going to really have to think about as we look at career preparation and pathways.
Looking at the shortage, looking at opportunities for students to have workplace opportunities.
So, there was a strong study session on that as well.
So, just to let you know that the CTE is really trying to think about credentialing issues related to the kind of initiatives that we're working on in our area as well.
Okay.
CCEE.
Thank you.
First, before I talk about the collaborative work, I just wanted to mention that President Kirst talked about appearing at the hearing at the Senate Assembly Education Hearing on February 15th.
Executive Director Cohen was also invited to testify at that hearing, and I was there to provide moral support.
But it's safe to say there's a lot of interest in the now what question of now that we have the dashboard rolled out and we are able to identify the number of LEAs that need assistance, who's going to provide that?
What does that look like?
And that's led to ongoing conversations both at the collaborative but also
substantive conversations with Superintendent Torlakson and Chief Deputy Price about what are their respective roles and responsibilities.
And you've all seen the schematic about providing support, a tiered support system of support.
So there'll be a lot more conversation about that.
I think we may have an item in May to talk a little bit more about that or there's some discussion at some point in the future because people are anxious.
And I think it's safe to say, and those of you who served on this body with Dr. Cohn know that he has a very wise and thoughtful approach to how we work with LEAs that I think is a little different than, not a little, radically different than how the state and certainly the feds have worked with LEAs in the past.
And it's hard for people to believe that.
that we really, it really will be a continuous improvement and it will be a support system.
So we've got a lot of work to do on that end.
To that end and the specific work of the collaborative, we met at February 2nd.
Got an update on, there's really three big pieces of work.
The collaborative staff is working with what's now nine pilot districts and they're quite diverse.
If you're interested in seeing the whole list, I encourage you to get on the collaborative website.
But just to give you a smidgen, they're working with a district out in Blythe, whose name escapes me, Palo Verde, out in Blythe, which is quite a small district, very, very geographically isolated.
Carl tells very compelling stories about that district, whose main industry is a state prison.
and what that means for the school system to Sausalito Marin City, which is in Sausalito, which is also a whole nother case study of interesting kind of racial isolation, with Kern County.
Kern County and the entire county is working as a pilot in all of their school districts that are in it.
and Anaheim Union, which is a very big district down in Orange County.
So lots to learn about that.
And again, the idea is how do you work right alongside those locals, identify what their issues are, what their successes are, and help them to continue to improve.
as opposed to the model we've had in the past, in my view, which is what's the recipe for everybody to do?
So, again, very different point of view.
The other big work that the collaborative is engaged in, I have mentioned this before, we have some early adopter peer-to-peer networks that have been operating for the last several months.
We're now ready to roll out the full implementation
There's going to be an RFP probably later this week for networks who want to get funding for over a two-year period of time.
This is kind of like what CORE has done, identify people who want to work together, but it's not just LEAs.
So there are networks of community-based organizations, for example, which is also very different than what we've done in the past.
The last big piece of work is the professional development.
You might recall that we had several workshops in the fall.
We're getting ready to kick off the spring workshops that actually start tomorrow in San Diego.
And there are 11 total workshops up and down the state.
We're having one in Santa Maria.
I think Board Member Sandoval suggested that we have more diverse locations, Ukiah,
Modesto, all up and down California.
They're all free.
Anybody can attend.
Anybody who's interested in attending, you can get on the collaborative website and sign up.
They also post all of their materials on the website, so their PowerPoint from the last training is on there.
and I'm sure they will post the PowerPoint for the workshops that are coming up.
The last piece of work is they're developing a content library of which the PowerPoint is part of it, but they're soliciting content that will be curated content from a variety of providers, so people that are interested, then that can be used.
It's public, open-source material.
So that's what the collaborative's up to.
I think that does it for that.
So we're now down to item 21, general public comment.
Is there?
Terry Burns from the California School Boards Association.
I just, Ms.
Williams, mentioning the AXA conference, want to remind you all to put on your calendars the CSBA annual conference.
It will be November 30th through December 2nd in San Diego.
Currently, we have the solicitation open for folks who want to do presentations.
At that, I would encourage you and folks who are watching online to submit proposals for presentations.
Thank you.
More public comment, please come forward.
How long do we have?
Three minutes?
One minute.
Okay.
My name is Robin Goldman.
One minute each?
Yeah, you could have one minute each.
Okay.
My name is Robin Goldman.
You probably got a million emails from me.
I'm here to talk about Ross Valley Charter and the fact that they are not viable.
They're conditionally approved and they've recently lowered their enrollment from 220 to 170 children in their petition.
Last night they had their lottery.
They admitted
They rolled over 143 children and they admitted around 30.
Right now, we have out-of-district kids displacing our in-district kids.
And the teachers of Ross Valley Charter, the proposed teachers of the proposed charter, have not resigned.
There's a huge amount of anger in our community because they submitted a Prop 39 and they are losing children from the in-district enrollment on a daily basis.
Please do not approve this charter.
It's conditional.
It's ripping our community apart.
The teacher resignations are all, everyone is angry and it's on next door on a daily basis.
People are pissed that it's just a terrible situation.
And we are here to plead to you to please do not approve it.
Okay, time, but you, these others have a minute if you want.
Each of you has a minute.
My name is Heather Bennett, and I'm also here on behalf of the friends and family of the Ross Valley School District.
Last night we sent you all a letter from the friends and family of the Ross Valley School District, and I'll read you just a bit of it right now.
As the friends and families of the children who attend the Ross Valley School District, we are writing because of an abiding desire to unify our community, which has been fractured due to the proposed opening of the Ross Valley Charter School, RVC.
We are advocates of the extraordinary learning experiences currently available to the children who reside in our high-performing but resource-challenged Ross Valley School District, the RVSD.
And we do not believe that the disruption and disparate impact that will be felt by the majority of our students, in particular by the subgroups that have been historically disadvantaged by the leaders of this proposed charter school,
is a reasonable exchange for their stated educational goals, curriculum, and teaching methodology.
Time.
Okay.
Go ahead, yeah.
Hi, my name is Erin Heath and I have a daughter in fourth grade at Wade Thomas Elementary School in Ross Valley School District.
I'm here today with an appeal, kind of echoing a little bit what they've just said.
Our district is really small.
We're not a basic aid district.
Our LCFF funding is inadequate.
But despite that, we have regularly been awarded California Distinguished School Awards.
And we're, generally speaking, in the tens for great schools.
And I think this is because we have some committed parents, we have committed teachers, and we have a fantastic school board.
And frankly, we're serving all of our students really beautifully right now.
So because of this, I do not support the transfer of public money from our underfunded but well-run and highly performing district to a charter that both our local and county school boards found to be financially risky and inadequately managed.
And morally, I cannot support a school that has been judged discriminatory.
This is my appeal to you.
If you could please very carefully scrutinize this issue and not approve this charter, our community would thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, that's the end of the public comment.
The board is adjourned.